Here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
First of all,
how many people get your name wrong when they try to pronounce it?
Well,
so many people,
I don't even care anymore.
I just had it where it comes out and cause I live in,
it's a funny name where I come from,
right from England who grown up was a funny name,
but in Mexico is even stranger names.
So I just normally make it Ian,
I my second name Grillo,
which in Spanish is glio.
Right.
So everyone,
I messed that up too.
If they see it spelled yes.
A microphone about a fist from your face.
Right.
There we go.
Um,
Yo on,
I don't think I've ever heard that name before.
Does enact a call young referred?
Was he in?
He's in fantastic four.
Oh really?
He's the stretchy guy.
Oh,
no shit.
In fantastic four.
So yeah,
he kind of,
he's made that name a little bit more,
a little bit more acceptable.
Um,
how did you wind up living in Mexico City?
So I came to Mexico or went to Mexico and the year 2000 and uh,
I'll kind of messed around for a few years in the UK.
What did the game to journalism.
So I found one way to get into it was to start working in a foreign country
rather than going to my local newspaper and work and go to a foreign country and
start working.
And I had a romantic idea about Latin America thinking I'd be like,
I saw the movie Salvador.
Ah,
you know,
Oliver Stone's movie from the 80s.
I kind of had a,
had a,
had a romantic idea about running around with grillers,
um,
fighting military dictatorships.
So I arrived in Mexico in 2000 and got a job at,
I had an English language newspaper.
How old were you?
27 when I first left the UK.
Yeah,
28 when I,
I messed around for a bit in Mexico as well,
and then got the job when I was 28.
Mexico City is a wild place.
Yeah.
It's so packed.
It's,
it's hard to,
I've only been there twice for a UFC events,
but every time I'm there I'm just shaking my head.
Like I can't believe how it's traffic works.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
18 years.
Nothing.
A lot of time in that traffic.
Nobody cares about red lights,
green lights,
they don't care.
It's stressful.
Everyone who wants to cut you up all the time.
Yeah.
People shout at you a lot.
You'd have to get used to people calling you like Ben Deco cerebral.
I tried different tactics,
not just try and relax and not get angry.
Did you know how to speak Spanish before you went there?
Yeah,
so I spent one year in Spain living in Spain before I went.
Now I spent a year in the Middle East as well.
Um,
and uh,
but yeah,
I started off when I arrived I spoke more to Spanish,
Spanish,
which is like all yet DLC on your deal.
And then I changed more to like the Mexican Spanish,
which was like,
oh,
your way.
Keep us all away.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So when did you start getting into narco journalism?
So like I arrived to say with the romantic idea about what I might cover in,
in,
uh,
in Mexico or Latin America and right away realize all that idea of grillers in
military dictatorships that have gone.
That was the last century.
Mm.
Che Guevara,
all that stuff had gone.
But right away when I arrived,
my very first off,
first I back in the UK,
grew up around a lot of drugs in the UK.
So going back to the eighties,
I grew up a lot,
people taking drugs.
I had a few friends who died from heroin overdoses back then for people I knew
died of heroin overdoses.
I had a sister who went to,
became a schizophrenia smoking a lot of,
a lot of went up.
She was,
became script schizophrenia.
Can their bill of drugs being smoked around that time as well?
Was it pot?
Yeah,
back then it was a Moroccan hashish.
There's,
there,
there is a connection,
you know,
and we've been exploring that a lot lately.
Um,
we,
we went into this,
uh,
marijuana debate between,
um,
uh,
Alex Borenstein and I'm Dr. Mike Hart from Canada and we talked about it and I
know people that have had that happen to them where they've had schizophrenia or
a psychotic breaks because of just massive doses of marijuana.
And especially people that don't do it or people that do it too much for too
long.
It does happen.
I had that debate.
That's one of the reasons why it came to mind.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't know a lot of people smoke weed,
a lot of people.
It's fine.
Uh,
now when,
when my sister had a breakdown when she was 18 and I was 16 at a time and when
that came out,
it turned out awesome.
My,
my,
my grandmother had an issue with schizophrenia and I think identity as a time
bomb waiting to go off or if it was how much the,
the,
the hatch was involved in that.
There's other issues as well.
So I don't really know the science of it,
but Ben way going back.
So,
so I've been around a lot of drugs before.
Um,
so when I arrived in Mexico,
actually one of the first,
uh,
first arriving in Mexico,
I ended up hanging around with some,
some people and they were smoking a lot of crack in Mexico.
It's one of some of the first people I met.
Wow.
Um,
I was,
I went down to the beach,
like backpacking down to the beach and these people were smoking,
smoking crack.
And I was like,
this is kind of strange.
I didn't know those people smoking crack down here.
So when I got a job at the local newspaper in English and I just started looking
at the crime thing,
one of the first deals I did was on the issue of crack being sold locally and
how that linked to the cartels.
And then very soon does very,
very quick.
I just fell in right away.
Like I said,
all these things happen by accident.
I just fell into covering the crime beat and this has gone back to 2001.
So 2001,
it was the same year that chapel was man escaped from prison.
Uh,
then I was calling a lot then to a great journeys from twiner has,
who's plan con ls.
You're a real legend from Tijuana who survived the shooting by it,
by cartels and you know,
phoning him up all the time.
Just getting him and had given me information can be tips.
And that is how it really started with that.
And our big store,
I did it back in those days was a,
the court marshal if some generals for drug trafficking.
And that was really where it began.
That'd been generals for drug traffic.
How much of an issue is that?
Uh,
I mean,
corruption must be
unbelievably ramping.
So I mean,
corruption even isn't necessarily enough word for it.
Sometimes I could state capture,
I'm gonna say this is the real beginning and it has been a whole crazy 18 years
of covering this stuff means this is the very beginning about,
and I've seen a whole lot of,
for a crazy stuff in that time,
but like,
just to get a sense of how bad the corruption is or what it really means and
the,
on the ground level,
they're like,
there's a policemen.
Let you interview policemen,
you get to know the policemen in a certain town,
certain city.
Um,
and it's hard to know in a hat or military guys are politicians and you want to
believe these are good people.
You want to believe there's good policemen out there who really want to stop
crime.
So there was one policeman,
his nickname was Tice at Dyson,
like Mike Tyson.
His nickname was Tyson because he was a world built bloke,
well built guy and uh,
he was friendly with depressed gut from Mitchell can friendly,
would depress.
Um,
and then it came out that he was actually a drug cartel member ranking member in
a drug cartel and he actually confessed,
they,
they used to have a thing where the police,
the federal police,
when they got him,
got him to confess on camera and he confessed.
Not only was he turning a blind eye,
not only was he carrying out murders,
he was training the young kids how to the capitate people,
how to cut people up.
And it was expanding in graphic detail how he like in a,
how they managed to cut limbs off.
Halle gets young people train the cut limbs off to get them to lose their fear.
So that's the level of corruption that could be a policeman you're dealing with
and that's really who they are.
Um,
so that's one of the craziest things about a corruption down there.
Did you have any hazards
Tinsey in getting involved in narco journalism knowingness?
I mean I would imagine that's one of the most dangerous
avenues to pursue in journalism.
So this was little by little,
I got involved in cover knee,
so like,
like going back to 2000 and this hadn't happened,
this war hadn't happened.
It was still like a crime issue at that moment.
So I began to cover these things.
And then around 2004 I got a job for the Houston chronicle out of Houston,
Texas.
I was covering,
I was a string of covering Mexico for them and I flew up to a lot to Nuevo
Laredo and there was a turf war beginning there,
which is really the beginning of the drug war,
which is toward Mexico.
Part began on the border with Texas in this city called Nuevo Laredo.
Over the bridge from Laredo,
Texas back in 2004.
So there was a lot of interest from the Texas newspapers,
what was going on as a whole bunch of bodies piling up there.
But again,
it's going back to these days and this is kind of innocent looking back,
innocent,
looking at myself then an innocent looking at what Mexico is like.
Then they would simply say,
go to the place I draw up the Monterey,
rent a car and just drive the car to Norbury either with bus by myself.
And now people just don't do that.
This is too much crazy stuff going on.
But back then it was still light or you can just do that.
So there was,
you see crazy stuff.
Like what kind of crazy stuff?
I mean,
now you can get stopped by an armed group driving on those roads.
He could,
you could just drive along and it could be a group of guys with guns could stop
the car,
get someone out,
takes take your way.
I mean,
there's a whole people a lot more careful about,
you know,
where you are now.
Now when,
um,
when you move around the roads,
you can be very careful how you move and how you plan this stuff.
You don't just wander by yourself.
Dry ran these places.
So,
so back then when this was happening and um,
there was,
uh,
this body's turning up and was trying to figure out why and,
and I,
uh,
there was one guy I interviewed who was a head of chamber of Commerce.
Um,
and uh,
talk to me,
no,
very interesting guy.
About a couple of weeks later,
he became the chief of police for the city and they asked him and said,
are you scared?
Um,
you know,
you scared about being killed?
He said,
no,
I'm not scared.
It's under the corrupt people who get killed.
And he was shot dead six hours after he gave that statement,
they shot him dead.
And that was one of the real markers.
If something really strange is going on in Mexico,
something is like going to erupt in Mexico.
Uh,
and then from there it kind of just escalated and escalated and,
um,
started working by the other media,
Time magazine,
New York Times different people.
Enough to what I said,
I can't do the,
I can't just write new stories about this.
I've got to write books about this because this stuff is big and it's
complicated.
It must be immensely complicated for the people that live there.
It seems like there's no escape.
I mean,
if
you can't turn to the police,
the police are the cartel.
There's the cartel,
the police,
all the politicians,
most likely if they're alive,
have to be compromised.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's been some varied,
very desperate people and I mean,
there's been some bird has been some inspirational people as well.
Fight in this.
There's been heroes.
There are heroes.
Um,
just to get more of a sense of what that means on the ground as well.
Uh,
I,
and I,
and some of the things you see,
uh,
you know,
some of the things that stay with me in Africa for a while,
it was quite romantic covering this.
It was like,
wow,
I'm covering,
I'm going to these places where chapel goes,
man is from,
you know what?
I've got up to the village of me's mother meets family.
I'm writing about these,
these crazy people,
but then you start seeing that the human pain in all of this.
Um,
one of many stories that stick with me was a mother in Monta Ray,
a school teacher,
you know when you have arm guys moving around,
they're also like,
uh,
really effecting the civil population,
had attacking the civil population.
And one mother,
um,
she was in our home with our two children in Monterrey and a,
it was like in the night,
just chilling in their house and in the door broke down and about 15 guys in
bulletproof jackets or came in long arms just taking stuff from the house.
How'd the family and I pinned him down and they said to the mother,
which of your children as the oldest?
And she was like,
didn't know how to apply.
I mean,
which of your children?
The oldest,
how do I grow?
How do I reply to that?
She just couldn't speak.
And the eldest,
Satya Tucson's one 18,
one 15,
the 18 year old was a philosophy student and he said,
um,
I'm on the oldest.
So like a Yukon with us and took them away.
The next day she got a phone call saying,
oh,
can we got your sign?
Give us this amount of money.
We'll give them back.
So she went round to like relatives just got the money.
She wanted to get the money right away.
She turned up with the money,
gave some money,
and then they just cut off the calls and she hadn't heard from him since.
And I,
I said miss seeing her face,
the devastation and the page that I,
you know,
just couldn't,
couldn't go on with life after that and just not knowing,
not having the closure.
And I met her when I went to report on one of the worst atrocities,
which was 49 borders,
who'd all been decapitated or had their hands and feet cut off and all been
dumped on a road and they would take them to the Morgan.
Monta Ryan arrived in the morgue.
I was inside.
The more to smelling the smell of the dead bodies is kind of weird smell you get
from like decaying flesh,
kind of a sweet smell you get from when you're around those places where you can
smell that the body is the k and I was inside the Morgan a came out is outside
the morgue and she was trying to see if,
if her son might be among those people,
among those bodies.
Wow.
But you know,
it's,
it's so insane that this is right next door to America and there's so little
effort put on doing something about it,
including doing something to mitigate the influence of illegal drugs by making
drugs legal.
I mean,
that would be one gigantic step.
You're,
you're not going to stop people from doing drugs.
I mean,
this is an illogical,
ridiculous approach.
I don't think people should do most of those drugs,
but when you make drugs illegal,
only criminals are going to sell those drugs.
And this is exactly what you have right next door to American.
It's just unbelievably insane that there's this amount of crime.
A drive away from San Antonio.
Oh
yeah.
And talking about that issue of the money and the economics of days.
So I mean,
you look at cocaine,
so you could say you've got the,
there was four main drugs,
now it's,
you've got fentanyl coming in as well,
and the,
and the cartels and making fentanyl,
they're making it,
making it yet.
And I made it and making it bring in precursors,
making it as a lab.
One lab,
I was in Nogales,
uh,
about a year and a half ago,
they passed a lab in Nogales rotten the border.
They'll make them have the lab they're making the finet Fenton in and bring up
eh,
but as well as that you've got out of the four main drugs,
historically a marijuana,
uh,
heroin,
cocaine and crystal meth.
And this goes back a hundred years.
Like so Sinhala,
which is the cradle of Mexican drug trafficking.
It's in the low,
is a bit like Sicily as to the Mafia and likes in an arrest and a Mexican drug
cartels where it began.
And it began right to go back to 1914 you had in the u s to Harrison's narcotics
tax act when they made a,
they restricted opium and cocaine in the United States.
And from 1915,
they began a cross border trade from Mexico to the United States.
So that's when it started all the way back then.
So over a hundred years ago,
some of the very first people doing it,
we're actually Chinese Mexicans.
They were Chinese immigrants that arrive in Mexico.
They began doing this,
they bought opium,
um,
from,
from China planted in,
in Mexico.
And some of the first people receiving it with Chinese Americans.
Some of these very early cases,
a case from 1916 investigated his documents about this case where there was
Chinese Mexicans trafficking to Chinese Americans here in California.
And at that time there was a governor of Baja,
California involved.
Um,
right back then.
What is the solution?
Is there any solutions to this?
Well,
I mean,
I get,
you know,
I think a lot of people covering this,
you get very weary.
You want to see solutions.
Um,
you want to find solutions and you want to come with that optimism of finding
solutions and you want to justify why you're doing this.
What you're doing is for not just to tell the stories but to look for solutions
to this.
Um,
and it,
it gets worried about that.
There's three areas.
I believe that our traditions first,
I do agree with you on the idea of drug policy reform.
Again,
it is tough uphill battle.
I mean going back to 2012 I wrote editorials about,
you know,
one of the reasons you should legalize marijuana is because of the marijuana
come from Mexico,
which goes to cartels,
which pays killers,
which pays for corruption.
But at the same time,
marijuana,
a lot of,
you know,
love is legalized in the United States and the violence has,
she just got worse in Mexico.
So you've also got the issue of heroin,
uh,
cocaine,
crystal Meth,
fentanyl,
and you've got the cartels are going to bunch of other rackets now.
They're still crude oil,
which is a big deal.
They still billions of dollars worth of crude oil criminals down there from
pipelines can tap into a pipeline or something.
Yeah.
You kind of pipeline you have,
you'd normally put in two taps.
You drill two holes in the pipeline,
you drill a hole to put,
to take the oil out,
you'd drill a hole to put water in to try and keep it equal.
Uh,
the pressure,
the same Dev you saw as a crazy video recently of a,
in a,
in a small town in Mexico where a bunch of,
there was a tap open of really,
really bad tap,
the origins spraying out and a bunch of people were lining up just to pick up
the oil from the pipeline and exploded and just,
it was just like crazy death toll.
Yeah.
I did see that from,
from,
from Nada,
but a bad way that I do believe in,
in a,
in drug policy reform,
we have to talk about,
this has to be on a table.
I mean,
Americans,
there's,
you know,
no one knows really what American spend on drugs,
but as the survey are where you can find on line if you just tap and what do
Americans spend on illegal drugs?
And it is an estimate of $100 billion a year.
So,
you know,
that amount of money I've been,
that's an estimate.
I mean,
it could be right.
You know,
it's hard to know how it's a very round number,
but like $100 billion a year.
Now,
if you think about that pumping into these cartels year after year,
I mean,
decades.
You know how much of that,
if it's 30 billion of that guide down in Mexico in over 10 years,
300 billion over 30 years,
close to a trillion dollars,
that really creates this,
this monster,
but know a secondary.
So I'm not believe in drug policy reform.
I mean,
I don't know how,
I mean Rehab,
they want to needs it because heroin addicts by lot of heroin.
So every one you save from that you can,
uh,
you know,
you can stop a lot of heroin and a lot of that money.
What does money goes to these people who are doing this stuff.
But a second area I believe is his social work.
Uh,
in the neighborhoods.
like I've talked to,
I've done a lot of interviews with particularly with the assassins,
with the killers in cartels in Mexico and also around Latin America.
I've been traveling around Jamaica,
Brazil,
Central America,
Colombia,
talking to a lot of the killers especially.
And when I sit down with them,
I try and get their life story.
Like how did they first get into this because you're not born doing this stuff.
And often,
I mean,
in some cases that is the different profiles.
There's some of them,
uh,
in noticed one,
one guy,
this is done in Honduras,
which is also crazy situation,
was a guy there.
I actually met him before I'd met him when I was doing some reporting down there
back in 2015.
And he was driving for us and he was also carrying a gun to help protect us as
with the journeys to that I had had,
had been hit before.
We've been actually shot before.
And,
uh,
then I met him again afterwards and gone to tell his story,
which is kind of typical of a lot of these guys.
And he described how he been abandoned as a kid by his parents and had this real
hate that he had with the world.
Like,
and I just fucked a world.
Um,
and he described the first time that he carried out murders.
and it,
this is us though.
I'm an he carried out.
They already doc,
he documented all these hits he'd done and to capitations he'd done in his kind
of crazy stuff.
But the first time a cat it,
a murder was probably the,
the,
the freakiest when he was I think 14 and they got a,
a family,
they went into a house,
I couldn't a lot.
They've got family and they butchered a family.
And he described when he described that and then described later on,
you know,
how he became a higher killer.
And the thing about him,
like some of these people you think they're psychopaths,
they just,
they really don't care.
But some of them really do have these conflicts inside the heart.
I think he was someone or a list of back to that interview and he had,
and it's hard to,
to balance that someone who does evil but also has it been a victim as well,
a victim and the victimizer.
And you feel that pain since,
since then he himself been been murdered.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
he's uh,
who's,
you know one,
so how you get social work to reach people from a very young age because often
they are recruited into organized crime when they're 12,
13 years old.
So he butchered his family when was 14 when it was his stealing money from them.
So the story would,
that was,
he said that he was hanging around with these basically street kids and one of
the other kids said,
I know where there's some money in a house,
we can get some money in a house.
So they went in there and killed his family and it turned out there was no money
there.
And the reason the other kid had said go there was because he'd actually been
living with his family and he said they'd been abusive to him.
So he wanted to like Rivett have revenge on his family.
Well what was so really sick of that is to when he was describing it was they
had this family and they would to stop them defending themselves.
They would like take them one by one,
like pin him in a,
in a room and take them one by one.
I'd take them out,
butchered them how the other ones didn't really know what was going on and
think,
I mean the action itself,
but how like teenage kids can think about that stuff.
And then later on when he was talking about the uh,
decapitations he was talking about they get contracts with the capitation inside
the quite like they say,
look,
we want this killing.
We wanted to to capitate a guy,
we want this doc,
we want to see video of the guy being the cap tech.
We want that.
We want the guy to suffer.
And when he hacks the heads off,
dare sometimes still be a moment when like when the life goes out of them and
when the body is still luck.
Twitching.
Lucky says they can still see like was there's a bit like nerves.
It was like a chicken,
like a headless chicken.
There's a bit as a part when he's still like twitching a bit,
even after day or you know,
they've lost a kind of seven there,
connections there.
Ooh.
Now when you're interviewing these people,
how nervous are you?
I mean this seems like if you're putting all this stuff down,
you could implicate them in some crimes and it seems like it would be very
convenient for them to try to get rid of you.
So is,
there's a whole bunch of different situations around interview.
So some labs,
I've interviewed people in prisons,
a lot of time in prisons.
Um,
you know,
this took me years to,
to get to a lot of these people.
First of all,
you know,
W it wasn't like,
uh,
um,
when I first started doing this I was like,
you know,
how do I get,
how do I reach them and start going around to drug rehab places and talking to
people in Drug Rehab?
I'm going into prisons and NCLR wireless.
I did a lot of interviews in and in one prison I got to know a lot of prisoners
and the prisoners [inaudible] in a Christian evangelical wing there and they
were going through this weird Christian in.
I like Christina in a discovery of God there and then through the street on the
street,
often light through content.
I mean we're old time through contacts on the street.
Um,
and in Honduras,
a lot of great contacts with a friend is a journalist who grew up in his
neighbors.
We'd,
all of these guys,
he just knows,
knows that his guys from growing up now.
Yeah,
there's different,
different things,
you know that have been bad situations.
I think anybody covering this has had some bad situations.
Sometime people get angry,
people threatened them and so forth.
But a lot of the time when it's,
when you talk to people,
yeah.
And one thing that you have to be very low Tom,
you have to be very stringent about protecting the identity and really serious
about that because there's been cases where various cases where other people
have interviewed killers and shown their identity either through the [inaudible]
face or through like some dumb thing being showed and they have been themselves
murdered in a butchered after these x given these interviews or like other
things are happened,
they'd been threatened or something to family or arrested or Sifo.
So you really got to protect people's identities.
Okay.
In a way in terms of when they talk and stuff and I didn't really feel nervous
when I need one of these people,
I probably feel more nervous hit or come to you.
That's just 40 kids.
It's like all the other on a big show.
It's a different,
a different thing when you're like talking to
first,
you know,
you start with easy questions,
like anything,
you start talking about how in a how you know people are human,
they're human beings and people have got it.
People are complicated and I haven't just interviewed and I've also got drunk
with somebody people and hung around with somebody.
People.
Um,
for times trying to get closer,
like,
uh,
you know,
spent time to try and understand their world a bit more.
What's the most time you've ever spent with these people?
Um,
in several days.
Several days.
Yeah.
Like a in I like I'm a now CEDAM see him again,
hung out with in a hangout with them.
I in different places,
not all the time,
sometimes just,
you know,
sit down and do interviews and just leave.
Uh,
but it's,
it's,
it's a complicated world for them is it's their normality knows if for them is
normal.
Uh,
it's,
it's what they've,
what they've lived,
what they've been through,
what's happening around them.
Um,
and this level of murder,
this happened a lot of parts of Latin American now it's crazy.
But in these areas is in his,
what?
He talked to other people who had just on the edge of this,
we'll have family members involved in this and it's just they're living this,
I mean,
these are levels of violence and it's interesting to compare historically these
levels of violence.
Um,
because you look at some of the worst cities like San Pedro,
Sula on Doris Caracas harm Sierra wireless,
and these are places which have levels of violence,
which are like way worst in medieval Europe,
a lot based in medieval Europe.
I mean,
look at the figures per hundred thousand because some of them have over a
hundred,
a hundred thousand,
150,
100,000 and medieval Europe a lot.
These cities were like 20 per hundred thousand.
So they're way worse,
way worse in the wild west than like now there are some place in the United
States,
the de la.
Oh.
And I did and I've done some research recently in Baltimore Marin hand and I was
kind of,
it's interesting to compare that to Latin America and that's a high level.
That's 40 by a hundred thousands that's not as the same level,
but it's significant still more than medieval Europe.
Yeah.
Wow.
Baltimore is worse than Medieval Europe.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask.
That gets,
you have to have to do some professors then they weren't in a like you get like,
you know they might be,
they might say,
well Jerusalem in this time or in a line I like,
you've got to try and it's hard to note that it really dig down exact club net.
There was outbreaks of violence and killing in certain places,
but the overall average of all average year,
that's a significant leap.
100% leap ea.
Absolutely.
Baltimore.
What about South side of Chicago?
It's not that,
I mean like the level I think in Chicago comes out around 20 or something,
so it's not now the Emerg that of the whole city.
Now these again,
and one of the things about the violence in the United States compared to Latin
America in Baltimore is,
is,
is significant bit of fairly what the city of Baltimore is a fairly small place
where they're talking about.
So in Mexico you have entire states that are like really violent or entire
countries in Latin America,
whereas in the u s it tends to be neighborhoods which are violent.
Um,
so if you really focus on the south side of Chicago,
it's probably similar levels to Baltimore.
Then,
you know,
it's a,
but if you look at the whole city,
you've got neighbors did a pretty safe in Chicago as well.
Now,
through all of this time that you spent down in Mexico,
have you seen it?
You've seen it escalate,
you've seen it get worse and worse.
Yeah.
So there was first this really big escalation happening in 2008 was the first
big escalation where it was a cause of that.
So you had,
there was a steady build up there was happening.
Um,
and then in 2006,
do you had the president fully pickar that on Claire to military crack down on
drug cartels.
And after that with those as big response and things started really getting out
of hand,
we'd already seen violence escalating before.
And in my idea,
my kind of theory behind this is that,
um,
you had in Mexico back in the 20th century,
more of a top down,
um,
centralized government controlling everything you had,
the Pri and power and they were basically,
they will have to coordinate through corruption.
So back then they'd have the drug cartels working for them and an interesting
story guy.
And back then,
the 19 day nine 70 store in a book called drug lord by Terence Popper who
interviewed,
uh,
a drug trafficker in the eighties when he got the,
his job is to ha have hit a plateau,
which is the head of a certain territory.
When he got the job,
he went with the state police at the time and said,
I want to become the head of the plaza.
And they took him in and tortured him for two days unlike,
and I beat the crap out of him,
put electric shocks on his nuts.
One of the big taught at Dmexco put water laced with Chile in his nose.
Smell like one of these big,
so your whole face burns.
He's a like torture techniques they have.
And after two days of torture him and said,
yeah,
well done,
you know,
you survived.
Well you've got the job.
So we know what it shows is that the police had the upper hand,
the police control this.
They were like,
okay,
we control this racket and you know,
we can fuck around and tortured and killed.
Rock rock was when we like,
uh,
you know,
in all up the presidency.
I mean,
there was a,
in that time,
Carlos Salinas became president in [inaudible] 94,
his brother Raul Salinas,
there,
there's the Swiss investigators,
bank accounts and said he had $500 million in bank accounts.
We say,
you know,
they,
they believed it was drug money.
So right up to the presidency,
this was was being run.
Ooh,
when makes a code change democracy.
So when I arrived in Mexico was changing to democracy and it's like,
wow,
great democracy is going to happen.
Free markets going to happen.
You know,
we're in a good days at a 21st century now.
But what happened was you'd look to political control shifted.
So you had a bunch of different political parties and they were fighting over
the drug trade.
And you know,
I was one time in regular echo when the federal police had a shootout with the
municipal police.
They were fighting each other probably because they work for different drug
cartels.
Wow.
So that's what started.
But then you had the techniques,
like the technique of beheading
wasn't really a big deal.
It was very,
very rarely used up until around 2006 and one of the first incidents was in
acapulco in 2006 in about June,
2006 now it might have been after inspired by the al Qaeda car,
we in a video which was shown him full of Mexican TV.
I remember when that came out,
when they'd decapitated the guy in Iraq
and they decapitate first it was two policemen,
Eddie capitate.
Later that year in September,
2006 there was five heads,
they rolled onto a disco dance floor.
And then his thing just became,
just escalating,
just became this kind of light using his terror public terror.
So 2006,
2008 was a big escalation and then 2011 12 were like crazy.
And then it subsided a bit in a pub.
The violence got bit less public and it was more like hidden,
like mass grave stuff.
Now the worst mass grave has been discovered so far,
um,
was in Veracruz.
I've been to the side of it and it was 250 bodies were found in this mass grave
in one place and it was right next to a housing estate.
And there's families who was,
so one of the saddest things was you sick.
You see their kid is bicycles and basketball hoops and stuff right next to this
and the field next to that,
they'd dub up 250 bodies and the smell was like emanating to this housing
estate.
And he's looking at a Middle Clark,
the dream of becoming middle class.
That was the,
the kind of in this housing state and right next to it,
this violence.
But when I say a lot of these stories and having been the crazy stories,
but a lot of the weird thing is a lot of Mexico lives in normality around this
is not what you,
this is not what you see every day.
This is why this happens.
But there's also just a normality that could just be like,
you're outside here in la.
And normal people living normal lives around this as well.
What is the response in Mexico?
Like what would it mean after they wanted to have this military action against
the cartels?
Obviously that hasn't really put a dent in it.
What,
what,
what's the,
the current thought process behind dealing with this?
So there's been a,
there's a bunch of like citizen,
um,
protest movement various times,
during these recent years.
And wire them was,
it was a very interesting gargled hobbyist,
Cecilia who is a poet and a writer whose son was murdered.
And He,
when it first happened,
his son was murdered and he just came out,
sis the press where he's like an icon.
There's just like,
this is just,
you know,
Mexico's gone,
I can't,
I can't deal with,
is my son's being killed.
And then he began talking in very now and then he went to the streets and people
coming out publicly,
um,
crying.
And it was one of the first times there's a realization,
a lot of innocent people dying with this and people come out.
And,
you know,
I went to some of these things.
People come out crying,
family members and she actually a sense we,
we're victims here because there's a,
for a long time since it's simply bad guys killing bad guys.
And that wasn't the case.
Now,
the current president,
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador who just won the election last year and he just took
power on December the first,
so he's got to mix things.
So one of them is this idea of the war's over.
I'm going to create peace,
we can have forgiveness,
reconciliation and up is hard to know what that really means.
And his second thing is we need to have,
um,
more of a unified state police.
So like what I described before about you had local police fighting the federal
police.
So we've got to have,
so he's got this idea now,
the national guard,
which is a kind of hybrid between military and police thing around,
and that's basically his,
his,
these kind of two thrusts he's in now.
He's only been in power for a couple of months.
January was still a bad month in terms of murders,
in terms of bodies.
Last year was more than 33,000 dead last year,
which is the size of Mexico,
the equivalent of the United States having close to 100,000.
Now imagine what that would mean in the United States.
If you had that many people dying in a year,
a month,
the whole year in a year,
100,000.
Yeah.
Now,
when these people are,
when they're being recruited by the cartels,
when the police officers are being recruited,
the big issue must be will they must be two issues,
right?
Safety.
Like if they don't join the cartel,
they probably get murdered.
And two,
the amount of money the cartel would give them would be far more than the
government would give them to be a legitimate police officer.
Yeah,
sure.
And that,
that's like a no.
Famously platinum blonde plateau,
plateau,
Poloma,
luck,
silver or led.
You want to have the silver of the bribe,
the lead of the bullet.
But,
but even beyond that for a long time,
a lot of these people who joined the police,
uh,
like from the beginning,
they're in.
I,
I've taught,
I've got,
I've got on video,
uh,
met a video back in 2010 in Sierra wireless of a bunch of,
of rappers just hang around in the middle of all this.
And one of their friends were saying,
and they were talking and these people were saying,
you know,
some of them been done for taking drugs,
have the board and they'd been in gangs and stuff.
And one was like,
I want to be a policeman.
And he was like,
I want to be a policeman and make some money,
you know,
basically through corruptions that as I said,
it is like that is the mentality of somebody.
People joining the police from early on.
Another guy,
Guy Open,
open a first book with his guy,
uh,
who,
who became policemen.
Um,
when he was 18,
he was basically a hard,
tough guy.
Pet American football from Durango,
became a policeman when he was 18 and into police learn to torture and learned a
murder.
He said,
that's what I learned in a place.
And it just at 20 after two years,
just left the place and went full time into crime.
And he's like,
so you know,
you've got a situation where you know,
it's not,
it's,
it's worse even as beyond that they're the bad,
a lockable might imagine of corruption.
God.
So
all of this essentially is escalated from the time you came to Mexico.
So when you came back to,
it sounds like you got in,
I mean,
if it was a story you got in at almost the perfect time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Horrible way.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
it's,
like,
you know,
you don't,
you don't do these things on purpose,
uh,
you know,
you don't think,
and if I look back 20 years ago,
I mean,
it's 18 years I've been in Mexico now,
I had grown up in Mexico and that,
in that sense,
I,
I've never looked back.
And I think that's it now in terms of myself seeing this.
I mean,
it's,
I think for anybody it's paced,
painful.
I mean,
how you process that level of depth,
that level of murder,
level of suffering.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it's horrible stuff to see and,
and,
and it's,
you could still have a lot of people,
um,
separated from that in our families.
People bring up children and,
you know,
you want to separate,
kids from that.
So off often,
like middle class kids in Mexico,
quite sheltered because families want to shelter them as much as they can from,
from,
from that violence and just,
you know,
not let them see that side of things.
How much of that do you have to deal with in Mexico City?
So Mexico City,
you know,
is about the same murder rate as Houston to Mexico City is not supervised now.
It's still not super safe,
but it's not super Vinad.
So Mexico City is kind of,
and there are parts of Mexico,
which of which are fairly safe now the state of Yucatan were meritorious is the
same murder level as Belgium.
So you've got oasis within Mexico where you don't have this level of violence.
So Mexico City is it and is a great city.
Mexico City is a great city to live in in many ways apart from the traffic and
the pollution and various things.
I mean,
there's a bunch of things that are,
and I know,
and I love all of Mexico and I love all of,
you know,
Latin America.
I love even,
and even the bad places I still love.
I enjoy going to these places.
I enjoy meeting people there in a hangout,
in his areas.
There's a lot of good things about him still.
But dealing with all the horrific tragedies that you report about and
experience,
do you look for an escape route?
I mean,
are you,
are you looking to get the fuck out of dodge?
Yeah.
How,
I mean,
um,
there's been different times where,
uh,
I,
I've thought,
you know,
I wanted,
I want to stop this now.
Uncover other things.
Yeah.
As a journalist.
And he's the other journalists doing that as well as the journey is called
heads.
Who says,
give Eric Great Mexican journalist who's just,
I just saw him at the,
uh,
tried of El Chapo,
over in New York and who's been covering this for years.
One of the,
you know,
really great Mexican,
uh,
correspondence is covered,
the drug stuff.
And he was like,
he just said to me,
our butter,
I've got some stuff maybe I can give you.
This is the harm.
I'm [inaudible] this.
And the last thing,
I'm going to do,
Catherine trucks now and I,
we love,
we know we'll sit.
We'll see if that's true.
Um,
I think a lot of the time you get,
you know,
you get caught still doing this stuff.
You a piston when you,
when you've covered something,
people will want more,
people are interested as a,
and there's relevance to this.
Um,
I think some of the other struggles beyond like the,
the danger in staff is simply,
I mean we'd journalism's in a bad way.
I love the media in a bad way.
Um,
and just simply getting know,
trying to be know I'm a free lance,
generous,
I love being a free last year and they started loving independence.
I love being a write books and crackle and write magazine stories and make
documentaries and do these things.
But like just in having the economic base for that,
you know,
see she's degenerate and lots in the time that I've been doing it.
Have you personally been targeted at all?
So there's a couple of situations or had,
um,
and I,
I mean,
first I,
when I know I'm going to have to give some
calm respect and,
uh,
condolences to so many colleagues,
Mexican colleagues who have been murdered and been,
had been murdered,
threatened,
had to leave the country and various things and they've had it bad.
Um,
including,
uh,
a friend,
a good friend,
a great colleague called Heavier Bell Desk who was shot dead in 2017,
May,
2017 in cooler can a guy I'd known since 2008,
um,
great guy,
got drunk with him in the Cantina,
very generous guy.
He wrote eight books,
a charismatic,
I mean,
you know,
really lovely guy who was shot dead and many other stories.
So,
so I kind of don't want to give my own compare Martin waste a lot of them in
many ways.
But yeah,
sure.
There's been times,
there's one time in a,
it was in the state called Mitchell Afghan and this was 2014 and there was a
thing that happened there when a lot of regular people rose up with guns against
the cartels.
They will known as outer defense as or like self defense courts and they rose up
to fight the cartels and uh,
they,
you know,
a bunch of guys with guns.
It was kind of crazy situation where there was his luck,
almost like a trench warfare happen between cartels and his self defense groups.
And then what happened was a lot of regular gangsters started saying,
well,
we're self defense groups as well,
you know,
just coming up saying,
oh yeah,
we're self-defence equips,
you know,
those guys are out in the street with guns,
we're just going to go out with our guns.
And so anyway,
I went down,
I drove down at the end of this have been that I've been covering this right
through and it had been fairly okay to do the self defense squads.
The outer defenses were pretty easy going to work with,
but I drove down there to,
to Mitchell can,
um,
and I wanted to do some stuff on it and I was going to meet a friend and our
journey,
she just backed out at the last minute.
I just went down there anyway and arrived there and there was about 50 guys
arrived in this place near the city called a passing Gan.
And there's about 50 guys who supposedly as defense squad in a parking lot
getting ready to go on a mission to try and take down this drug trafficker
called lap Dota.
And they were like,
they were sitting there.
It was a guy who like signing them up for this kind of mission.
And there's a bunch of guys they were,
and they had very heavy weaponry.
They had AK 47 is that our 50,
is that grenade launchers,
um,
on there,
on the top of their guns and beneath their guns.
They had like the grenades strapped to them.
Lastly,
grenade on belts,
round them,
ammunition belt around them.
I'm not crazy.
Like,
you know,
like,
are you see the old revolution we stopping?
I mean,
like real crazy,
like this Broadway stuff.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
I was talking to them,
I realized quickly this would not self defense guys.
These would narco,
these were gangsters.
Them,
they,
you know,
they came out with it,
right?
They're like,
um,
you know,
I hadn't,
you been in the self defense movement?
Oh,
a couple of days now.
And they're like,
and then they had like guns with like diamonds and hair fe,
um,
heifers down the boss.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I was getting were not okay.
When does,
it was kind of like,
um,
you know,
joking with his guys and take some photographs of them.
So they were posing for photographs,
so it was sitting there with a,
like,
posing with the guns and stuff in there and they said,
they said they have a,
the word Wedo is,
is like,
um,
it's not really white boys like Blondie,
you know,
it could mean like,
if,
if you're,
you're white in Mexico,
he often get called a wetter.
So like,
where it all,
um,
how much the prostitutes costs in your country.
Like Gretchen did that you'd have to go there and see it.
There's like a Weirdo or do you like take,
do you like taking meth?
Do you,
don't you know,
you like,
like taking meth?
Uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm okay.
And I,
there was still like,
no,
you're kind of joking.
And this guy turned,
came up among them and he said,
uh,
the,
I tell the other guys and the first of the big guy,
and he said that he was carrying a big guy and he's got there woody,
massive head.
And he said to me,
a bit aggressive,
he just don't take my photo.
I was like,
yeah,
no problem.
I won't take your photo.
And then a guy came up and said to the other guys,
say,
what are you doing this the Da guy here?
He said,
the agent among you taking your photographs,
um,
you know,
what are you doing?
And I was like,
no,
I'm not,
I'm not even American.
I'm British.
And he said,
no,
you know,
this is a DEA guy.
My,
my,
my brother was arrested in Texas and the Dea guy pretended to be a journalist,
you know,
some bullshit story.
And I said,
look,
I can,
you know,
I can show you my website.
So they've got the cell phone out and,
and look through it,
his cell phone and found out my website.
And the guy calmed down a bit and he said,
you know,
if you,
if I see you,
I'm going to put a bullet in your head,
I'm going to throw a grenade at you.
Is it?
He added.
So I left in,
I kind of tried to talk about a left and uh,
yeah.
And,
and they went and then I didn't publish the photographs I've still got and I
both to photo ops and one of the guys sent me an email saying what happened to
photographs,
my emails and my website.
So I just ignored it.
And I think a lot of them got killed in a big fight they had with the federal
police afterwards.
So that was one.
Um,
and it's been,
yeah,
it's been a few more.
So it's a lot of touch and go.
Yeah.
These situations.
The,
the federal police,
do they have a plan to try to eradicate these moms or is it
a lot of lip service?
Like,
is it really possible to radically these gangs or is it just one of those things
where they say they're going to do something but they have to kind of protect
themselves?
You know,
there's,
there's been different different times.
I mean sometimes there's been the federal police have done well done after a
particular guy or sometimes with the Americans.
He no doubt been a,
um,
in our rest of very many significant kingpins,
the problem is his word is the door doing a deeper questions is that like when
you take down some of these kingpins,
you've always got other people who will fight over their same territory.
So for example,
you take out Chapo Guzman and then you get a fight among his sons and some odd
one of his lieutenants over it,
over the empire.
Now what's happened,
and one of the reasons the violence has increased in Mexico is because they've
had this onslaught attacking cartels over the years.
Then you end up with like the lieutenants then taking over and then their
lieutenants taking over and then their lieutenants taking over.
That's what happened in Chicago as well.
Or I spoke to a police officer in Chicago and he said the violence escalated
afterwards.
Some big gang rests.
And once they had gotten,
some leaders have some gangs and other people tried to fill the void.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
The sound.
So,
so then you get some of the people who are in power now,
uh,
like very young,
very violent people and people who are not as smart when those not as mature,
not calculated.
Yeah.
So,
so you to you and also you end up with these,
the fragmented territory.
So you have people controlling rather than having big cartel,
some leader who controls it and a half the country you end up with these cartel
lethal allowed these gangs controlling a part of the state now has one state
called good Arrow,
which you've seen this really light cartel fragmentation and you've got maybe 12
different groups in this one state and you get like a place where they're going
to one controls controller up along a road and then in our group controls it
passing a certain point.
So there was some,
some friends went up there,
um,
seven journeys went up there and got held up on this road up there 2017 as well.
And they got,
were in a car going like they're two vehicles and about 200 guys blocked the
road and the leader of this group was a guy I believe called [inaudible].
Um,
like again,
his name,
blondie,
polite and he's like maybe 23 years old,
like 200 guys there.
They said some of the kids,
I talked to,
one of the friends who was there and he said some of these are kids who was the
youngest like 10 years old among this mob of people.
And they,
they held him up,
they took away their VH one of the vehicles.
They took away all their laptops,
cameras,
all that equipment,
stuck them in the car,
two go.
Do you have to be careful when you're traveling that you have like a,
an obviously expensive laptop or camera,
something along those lines.
I think from the point of view of his,
you know,
they can,
they can take it away.
I'm going and it's happened a lot,
a lot of cases recently,
colleagues just being robbed.
Um,
I mean you get like an armed group and the take away that basically the hold
them down,
take all their stuff.
So you don't know sort of going,
I know various colleagues,
photographers,
and if you're a freelance photographer and you lose a good camera,
uh,
then,
then in there like,
you know,
some of the TV people would have,
they have less expensive cameras and they used to,
I remember a few years ago,
a TV group,
uh,
interviewed some gang members are in Honduras and they stole their camera.
And it was at that time it was like an $80,000 camera and the TV network on a
say of what are the TV network apparently was more pissed about losing the
camera.
It was about these guys,
you know,
again,
[inaudible] now having guns pointed to them.
What is the attitude in Mexico?
Uh,
a special amongst people who are studying the narco wars with all this,
uh,
build that wall stuff,
all this,
what's going on in America?
There's this,
this is very strange,
right?
Versus left polarization over here about whether or not there should be a wall
between the United States and Mexico.
Sure.
I mean,
well,
I mean the thing Mexican's are obviously very anti Trump in Mexico.
It's in a farm and I,
Trump is very unpopular from the very beginning when he said,
I know they are rapists and murderers.
Yeah.
Someone's doing the raping.
How many?
He's kind of United.
You look at surveys,
the level's very low.
So is anybody like me?
Trump in Mexico?
I was there.
Like there's always contrarians.
I've seen numbers like,
you know,
people will say like 80% or something.
I think he's terrible.
Sent means they must be at 20% somewhere else.
Don't.
I haven't met a Mexican who's been like pro Trump and I never have.
I met a Salvadoran who was pro Trump one time in,
in the heated guy had been deported and he was like,
I know you'll get,
you know,
this guy,
Trump's going to turn out to be a great president.
So,
so I see that.
But you know,
Mexico's very,
very anti Trump in terms of the wall.
I mean there's,
you know,
there's,
in terms of what
I intended,
the smugglers,
mom was talking to a smuggler in Nogales about this and he was describing he,
he'd smile.
He was from Nogales,
from a neighborhood called Buenos Aires,
which is right on the border with the United States.
He has no god,
Sonora,
Nogales,
Arizona.
So in August,
um,
so Noriega and Garth's Arizona.
And he was from the neighborhood right on the border there.
And he described that he first took people over the border of the United States
back in the 1980s when he was at school.
He's a high school.
And the reason was that that time was just an old fence and there was a hole in
the fence.
They used to go through into United States and go back into Mexico to send old
wire fence.
And the first time he took people through,
people would arrive from southern Mexico saying,
how do we get to the US?
And he'd say,
Oh,
you know,
this way.
And they give them a tip.
He said the first time he got the equivalent of about 50 cents was what you made
to take people to the United States 50 cents.
Nowadays,
the cost of going into the u s is $5,000.
That's what you paid to go legal in the United States.
5,000 bucks.
So we were saying,
wow,
look at that increase every time that the u s puts more security,
it means it's more expensive.
When it's more expensive,
that means more money going to criminals,
which means there's not an industry doing it.
So now the cartels make a big percentage of that money of human smuggling into
the u s um,
by luck in terms of the wall,
I mean the,
uh,
wait,
when Trump first came in,
he had the line that Mexico's going to pay for it.
Yeah.
And,
and then it was this kind of line in a right.
The beginning,
he kinda,
he threatened Mexican president saying,
if you,
if you don't agree to pay for the wall and why are you going to come and meet
me?
And then it was like,
wow,
he's really going to try to shake down in Mexico for like billions of dollars.
Is He really going to try and do that?
Uh,
and that was kind of scary moment.
Then think from point of view of Mexico when he first got to powers lie.
He's going to do that and then he's going to deport 3 million and he's going to,
you know,
he's going to kill Nafta.
Yeah.
Actually those things haven't really come to pass.
Actually,
if you look over the last couple of years of Trump has some really hit Mexico
very hard.
So the concern was that he was going to take money that should be allocated to
other ways.
It's going to help Mexico and he was going to try to take that and use it to
build the wall.
I mean,
no one really knew when he first came in.
He's like,
oh,
Mexico's going to pay for this wall.
Right?
The Wall just got 10 foot higher.
I remember that.
Yeah.
It was light.
It was like in a,
how are you going to do that?
You're going,
are you going to start threatening Mexican militarily and say,
give us money?
I mean,
it was kind of like,
uh,
like is it a,
is it a shakedown?
Good to shake down.
It was kind of,
it was kind of a crazy diplomatic thing when he first got here.
So that was kind of scary for a moment from the point of view of Mexico.
But I think after you look at the last couple of years,
yes,
I'm really hit Mexico with and now he wants to build the wall.
Now as he does it,
there's the big fasten in terms of the spending here,
but if he wants to build it,
uh,
or Extendix,
there is warden sections of the border.
We're ready.
If he wants to extend it,
you know,
it won't stop.
A lot of the hard drugs.
I mean,
if you look at heroin,
cocaine,
crystal Meth,
high value drugs,
they normally go through the ports of entry,
right?
So shipping.
Yeah,
I mean they go,
oh,
or through the,
through the ports of entry through Leica.
I mean you have a through in cost,
right?
Because trucks,
I mean,
you,
you go through,
if you look at the Laredo in Laredo,
Laredo,
one of the reasons that was a big fight in the war started there in Mexico
because that's a very valuable territory.
There's something like 8,000 trucks go over that border every day.
Now,
if you have 8,000 trucks,
how many of those can use search in a day?
And also the way they can hide this stuff in trucks,
they can hide drugs in like a metal.
They can put them in,
in,
in some kind of metal container,
seal it up,
soldier it up,
put a bunch of,
so who doesn't smell?
So somebody has to say,
I'm going to open that with a blowtorch.
And as a searching after rip that vehicle apart to find the drugs,
they were putting them inside wheels.
Yay.
Mass inside ties and stuff.
That's like the,
that's like,
there's song,
there's a,
is it,
that's one of the older tricks from the,
like the 70.
There's a song that is,
uh,
one of the first narco corridos their drug ballots.
Um,
Eh,
it was called contraband and trend treason for the 1970s and that was about
hiring,
uh,
hiding marijuana back in the nine tires back then.
But yeah,
me now,
the trap cars now,
like super sophisticated,
they have some weird trap cars.
We have to do like a bunch of stuff like open the door,
move some staff to actually to actually open file the drugs.
Other slight,
some trick sort of door has to be actively.
Yeah,
I would imagine if there's a will,
there's a way there's that much.
I mean,
I remember hearing that from,
it's not a reliable source,
but from the Sopranos there we're talking about only 20% of all the shipping
containers or get brought into America gets searched.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So,
so,
so to the,
the hard drugs and learned a lot of time on through the,
the,
the ports of entry and,
and they have their data and other classic trick they have is you get,
they allow some to get busted.
So you allow one guy to get busted and they set somebody up.
So they're taking some drugs through,
they get,
they get busted or the f entities on them,
and then meanwhile more drugs are going through.
And is this the United States border?
That's tests.
That's catching this guy.
Yeah.
So they're not getting,
they're not getting tested in Mexico as they crossover,
right?
It's only in the United States border.
Yeah.
Some,
sometimes they might catch him in Mexico sometimes,
but the majority is gonna be the United States.
So the United States border patrol guys,
are they ever caught being corrupt?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
There's been cases of us,
border patrol and customs entry people who have been,
yeah.
Caught taking a bunch of money,
taking bribes,
allowing in our land certain cars through the course Sandvik was through.
So yeah.
How does one fix this?
I mean,
if you had a magic wand,
you were going to wave it over Mexico and fix this problem.
Like if you,
if somebody said you on,
you're a smart guy,
you've been in the business for a long time,
we're going to let you dictate how this takes place.
So I'd say,
yeah,
three things.
So like drug policy reform.
So we've got to talk about how we deal with his drug situation.
So I mean like a mirror.
I mean,
I mean some of that is,
is here,
isn't it?
And you probably got a better idea than me about how to,
why American,
what Americans takes so many drugs.
I mean I got from a drug taking myself in the UK,
our guess.
So maybe it's not that different.
I think there's a lot of answers to that.
Uh,
the biggest one is entirely that most people don't enjoy what they do and they
want an escape.
I think that's probably the biggest one.
The,
there's some ridiculous number that was just a,
we're just who discussing the number on the podcast have a,
how many people actually was it?
It was a Johann Hari,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
He was talking about the number of people that actually enjoy their job.
67% people have in this country don't like what they do or you know,
are just
sleepwalking through their life.
There's a another significant percent that hate what they do.
And then there's a few leftover that love what they do.
I mean it's a very small number of people maybe like myself or maybe like
yourself that actually enjoy what they do for a living and feel like they're
following their passion.
Most people were just working a job and they fucking hate it.
And then when they get off work,
they want to get fucked up.
And a lot of these people,
you know,
they're,
they have psychological issues.
They're suffering from abuse,
childhood abuse.
They're trying to,
I mean there's been some significant statistics about childhood abuse and how
many people from childhood abuse wind up using and abusing drugs and becoming
addicted and even overdosing on drugs.
And it's ridiculously high.
It's about pain,
pain and suffering and trying to remove that pain and suffering from your life.
And um,
you know,
people that don't know how to make healthy choices and don't have friends that
are making healthy choices and don't know what to do with their life.
That's a big,
big part of it.
There's another part of it that's because it's illegal cause something about
things that are illegal that are intoxicating and enticing.
You know,
when you look at the statistics in Holland in particular where marijuana has
been,
you know,
you could buy it in coffee shops forever.
Not that many people smoke marijuana in Holland.
It's a lot of,
uh,
marijuana tourism,
especially back in the day now that America has legal marijuana almost
everywhere.
Not a lot of people are going to Holland specifically to get fucked up.
But there was always the thing,
man,
when we were younger,
it was always a guy.
He's going to go to Holland and go get high.
Like
I won't know.
No,
I used to go there,
one of the teenage well but never there for some of that on a,
on a,
on a boat and arrived in Amsterdam,
uh,
back in those days.
Yeah.
It actually,
it made me,
made me swell small.
What you're saying is they're about enjoying the job and is true.
I mean,
when he said that,
um,
I do love what I do and enjoy what I do.
So that's what Intel is one of the size of that thing.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
so,
so I mean,
in terms of the issue of drugs,
we have to talk about this.
How can we stop American stop spending that money or allowed that money if it's
going to be spent not to be going to a black market and Andy stabilizing these
countries,
but also a lot of issues in,
in Mexico as well.
Uh,
like again,
that social work,
how do you change the reality?
And again,
so you know,
people who are abused and suffer taking drugs,
but people who are abusing suffer in Latin America becoming assassins.
Yes.
Because one of the weird things,
and on a,
on a moral level,
on a level of morality.
And I knew a lot of kids growing up who sold drugs and there wasn't really an
amazing and moral thing to think about in I sell drugs.
He was an easy step to take on a sim out,
sell some weed,
and then I'm gonna sell some speed and sell some ecstasy and then layer on
heroin or would ever,
but for somebody to commit a murder,
that seems like a bigger,
a lot bigger deal.
How'd you get into,
how'd you crossed that line to becoming a murderer?
How do they cross that line so
easily?
Well,
I think it goes back to that young boy that you were talking about,
the butcher,
that family,
he was abandoned and angry and hurt.
So much pain and the suffering,
that's often the case.
They want other people to suffer when,
when you see people that are doing terrible things to be,
but they're almost always suffering.
They're almost almost always wanting other people to feel what they feel.
They're lashing out.
That's,
uh,
that,
that social work aspect that you're discussing so critical and something that
we've discussed about this country that how few people are putting,
I mean,
how,
and very few politicians,
very few people that are running this country are putting efforts into try to
heal these communities that have suffered from just years and years of systemic
racism,
years and years of just embedded poverty.
That's almost impossible to escape years and years of crime and drugs and just
growing up in this community of despair,
this is what you were talking about with Baltimore.
This is what we're talking about with south side of Chicago and various cities
all over this country.
It just,
they don't get better,
man.
They date stay fucked up.
You know.
Um,
I had Michael Wood who is a police officer from Baltimore and he was discussing
what it was like being in Baltimore as a police officer and then looking at some
documents from the 1970s that detailed the crime in the very same areas that he
was patrolling in and this the same crime in the same areas.
And this sense of just overwhelming futility.
Like there was nothing that he was going to be able to do.
There's going to put a dent in this,
cause this was a lot of,
it was a product of in these areas in Baltimore where there was law that you
were not allowed to sell homes to black people in these certain areas.
So they kept these people in these poor areas.
And even though they had this desire to escape into the,
the more affluent or safer communities,
they weren't allowed to for a long time.
I mean,
there's so much of that in this country that the,
you know,
the people that are in control,
but everybody just wants to get elected.
Everybody just wants to,
you know,
and then once they get elected,
then they're looking to get reelected.
So they spend a gigantic percentage of their time campaigning.
No,
there's no universal effort on the part of all the citizens of the country to
try to look at all these areas and say,
hey,
these,
this is us.
You know,
just because you don't live in the south side of Chicago,
that those are human beings.
Those are just like you.
And I,
you could have been them.
They could have been you.
If they were you when you were them,
wouldn't you hope that you would help?
Wouldn't you hope that someone would come in and try to fix this area?
Someone would try to Portman.
We pour so much money in the foreign countries we pour so much money in is
subsidizing various industries that a lot of people disagree with.
You know,
and there's,
I mean,
I'm not an economist.
I Dunno what economic sense that on any of that stuff makes.
But I do know that money is allocated in a lot of different ways and the idea is
that it's going to be better for all of us.
Well,
it's not better for all of us to keep these communities as fucked up as they are
right now.
And there's no effort,
nothing.
Very little done.
No movement,
no change,
no gigantic step,
no,
no 10 year plan to eradicate gang violence.
No 10 year plan to radicating illegal drug sales and murder.
So the,
this great social work,
they're awesome quest social workers down there and said it.
Awesome heroes in these places.
And they're somebody I talked to a lot based set up YDS,
[inaudible] Sandra who grew up in the neighborhoods.
You're one of the first people to introduce me to a young gang members in this,
in this area.
Um,
she used to work in a factory,
they're going to social work and now she's a psychologist and she,
yeah,
she,
I mean she's somebody who who really will do the work and reach people and,
and like save lives.
Um,
and you know,
somebody,
you know,
basic stuff you really get in the community and try and reach and they have to
reach the kids when they're often 12,
11,
12 and you can often see in these areas who are,
the kids are going to get into this,
who are going to be recruited by the cartels,
who are going to get to gangs because there's certain profiles in these people.
They haven't got their families.
I was talking to some guys in,
in also set up wireless from the battery last Deca,
which is the,
one of the big gangs there started in the u s actually among prisoners in spread
into Mexico and became almost like a paramilitary group in Mexico about how they
recruit people.
And then this guy was saying,
look,
you know,
we will see in our,
I can see from these young kids who's going to be able to kill and you know
who's going to be a real fight and who's not.
And if these people have gotten parents who love them and so forth,
these guys aren't going to,
aren't going to,
they're not going to work for me.
I need,
I need someone who's like got hate,
who's calling to anger in them.
And I can,
I can do something with one of those.
It's kind of about the perverse opposite of this stuff really.
But so if people don't have that families,
and this makes my guess,
think a bit more sympathize,
I guess as well too.
You know,
the,
the idea of how important family is,
handball and loving parents is,
you know,
whether you're together or separate,
leaner,
loving parents,
you know,
having that and uh,
uh,
but if you don't have that,
you know,
you need social work and new people are going to offer something and try.
And now though there was a,
an interesting mayor of Midian,
good,
Andrea Guajardo and he had these ideas of trying to change the reality of the
city and he said,
I'm going to build the most,
he was a mathematician.
So I've got to see us as a mathematical problem,
this issue.
And I'm going to build the beautiful building and the ugliest part of the city
and the worst part of the city to make and force people who want to see.
We made a conservatory and put it in there in the poorest neighborhood so that
people who want to be in this conceptually have to travel to the poorest
neighborhood and go there and try and change the reality.
Because if you see around you,
a horrible neighborhood at dusk street,
no light,
nothing working in a,
what do you turn into?
And if you see a nice environment around you,
can you change people that way?
Wow.
How did it work?
It for a while,
it's hard to know exactly because also there was a,
a truce between some of the gangsters there as well for awhile.
Um,
was it related to the construction of the conservatory?
I,
the theme I have met and have the government was involved in the Theresa on
truth or not,
but there was for a time the murder rate did drop quite dramatically in Midian.
Um,
I,
not that I have people have carried on in a bit meti and has improved.
And Medi Medi in Columbia was the worst,
the most violent city in the world back in the 1990s and it's not in an
industry,
you know,
people do like their city now in Midian.
Wow.
So it had some impact.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And the social workers,
I'm sure they have some impact on individual people,
but I would imagine that the overwhelming volume of children that are being
recruited,
that it's very hard to put a real dent in it.
But I think in out quite has it had an effect because when that was the most
violent city in the world around 2010,
2011 and now is this turf war there between the Sinaloa cartel,
which is Chapo Guzman against local widest cartel.
And there was a,
there was 9,000 killed in that city over four years of that,
of that war.
It was crazy.
I was covering,
covering it then to just driving around from scene to scene and be like,
yeah,
massacre here.
Masker they're just driving around,
Bang,
this things happening.
And afterwards there was a lot of social work put into the city.
Um,
and Sandra described by lunch,
they said there's,
there's,
uh,
um,
I like a waterfall of,
of aid money coming in.
There was like us in a USA ID and stuff.
We stopped putting money into this and other different groups and the murder
rate did really drop.
So,
and it hasn't gone back up to that level since.
So I think it does have a real effect when it's put as a policy.
Um,
and it does have an effect on these things.
But also when you,
you talked a little while ago about a magic wand on this,
I mean,
in making a police force that actually protects the community or making a police
force that has some kind of effect.
I mean,
I grew up in England,
which is in a pretty safe place,
relatively in Nice and not like police and you know,
hate the no beer anti police would ever growing up.
Um,
and now I appreciate,
wow.
You know,
you have police who actually protect community in some way and the same in the
United States.
I mean the United States,
the police do protect people to a large extent compared to these countries.
And in obviously the tissues,
here is our issue of racism and killing and violence and so forth.
But still,
I think a lot of the people who,
who believe that they know,
a lot of people believe they have guns for self defense.
And I respect the right to have constant for self defense.
But really in America you're generally safe because the police are pretty hard
on clamping down.
But how do you create a police force which really has the will to protect people
in a,
how do you have that,
you know,
uh,
with the,
the word and the passion and the commitment to help people in Mexico.
That would be,
that'd be a dream.
The people that have dealt with police officers that are corrupt have a very
difficult time hearing what you're saying right there.
Those people would be angry or what you're saying saying,
no,
the police officer's here are corrupt.
They are bad.
There is racism.
There are real problems.
Yeah.
Um,
and there is,
but I think there's also real problem being a police officer,
period.
I think police officers have an insanely difficult job and I think most of them
are dealing with PTSD.
I think there's a giant percentage of them.
Like all over the world and in America too,
that are constantly dealing with violence and the threat of violence and
arresting criminals and being shot at and people lying to them.
I just don't think,
I think most people are very ill equipped to handle something like that.
I mean,
I agree there's,
there are definitely problems with the police and there are problems.
I mean,
the police shootings are rare,
very real problems.
Uh,
please,
killing innocent people here is very real.
Uh,
and you've always got to look for improvement.
And you know,
there's people,
families against suffering from that,
from that violence.
I don't want to belittle this.
No,
no,
you're not.
I know you're not,
I just have to sort of clarify because I know so many people would be hearing
this and going,
yeah,
Mexico is terrible.
The United States,
there's,
I mean,
there's a ton of videos.
The real issue though is we're also dealing with the sheer number of
interactions of police have with people with the vast majority of them are fine.
Yeah.
The sound,
the,
the other thing,
like,
say that the crime of kidnapping kidnappings are horrific.
Uh,
antisocial crime.
I'm a horrific crime and his choice lives.
Um,
there's one video,
a really video,
which really made me sick,
um,
which was given to a family of a kid of buck,
a 14 year old kid who was taken and they were,
they send this video to his family in Mexico and they were beating this kid and
saying to this kid,
you know,
this is this,
you in the go center camera.
This is your fault bitch to the mums is your fault.
Look how your kids getting beaten now you're going to give me the money.
So I'll ask him for like,
uh,
was it $200,000 for time?
Um,
and those kinds of crimes and a kidnapping doesn't happen in the United States
on a very big level because you've got effective law enforcement.
So some,
I mean,
our house,
I was at one conference and those are real nice,
real nice guy,
but there's people calling for the abolition of the police and they shouldn't be
a police force saying you really want to live.
Like when no police,
you would only live with a dysfunctional police when they can just kidnap your
kid
and like send a video to like that and you've got no protection from that kind
of thing.
Right?
I mean,
there's definitely problems here,
but also you've got to see the,
the,
the other side of having completed dysfunctional police force and what that
means.
There's just such a staggering difference between the United States and Mexico
in that regard in regard to gang violence,
drug violence,
just overall murders and the stories that we hear from over.
It's so different.
The fact that you could just draw a little line in the dirt,
he crossed that line.
You're in hell.
And then you cross this line.
You're in Houston.
I mean,
that's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I'm an a,
again,
I'm in,
I'll get criticized sometimes from a metro,
sometimes Mesic Mexican government sources or Mexican tourism sources.
And I like,
I'm covering this stuff so,
and I'm shining the worst.
Um,
and it can give it a story picture sometime because you know,
when I tell a story of 49 decapitated bodies with the hands and feet cut off,
people think,
wow,
you know,
as soon as you say this stuff,
when some guy describing cap there and people with this kind of does,
um,
you know,
if not people outside.
And I don't say it was well as that it is still is a great country.
I still,
you know,
a lot of the United States.
Um,
but I,
I probably love Mexico more.
And what do you love more about Mexico besides the food?
Uh,
I'm an,
I would say generally the atmosphere's good.
I just feel uh,
feel people are nice generally.
I think despite all of this horrific violence,
do you think it's because they don't have the same sort of a ruthless ambition
that people in the United States have?
I think there is a sense,
we were talking before about why people are into drugs.
And one thing that occurred to me is this kind of hyper competitiveness of
society.
And people can feel like failures.
Like if you feel like a fairly,
if you feel like,
I guess maybe social media affected this as well because you see what people
have and you expect you to have more and you feel you haven't lived up to it.
I think in Mexico people,
if you're broken the United States,
if when you come often maybe feel like a personal failure,
how come you living in America and you're broke,
right?
Um,
whereas in Mexico lots of people are broke so he like,
you know,
it's like you don't feel that same kind of personal failure with that.
When I'm there,
one thing that always strikes me is how happy people seem and that I think
there's a certain stress level that a lot of Americans put themselves into where
they're constantly pursuing material possessions and material wealth and success
and that oftentimes this leads to really exacerbated stress levels and it's not,
it doesn't make you happy.
Like the whole idea of having things in our mind is a,
someday if I buy this car,
I'll be happy.
If I live in this neighborhood,
And then,
so they work 12 hours a day to try to achieve that dream and they're never
happy.
And they're always stressed out.
And even though the vast majority,
the United States,
I mean there's some insane number 34,
if you make one $35,000 a year,
you were in the top 1% of the world.
So there's a giant percentage of this country that's in the top 1% of the world.
Yet the overall happiness level,
at least from what I've read,
is quite a bit below the people in Mexico.
Yay.
I mean,
yeah,
a lot of these things.
I mean,
how,
yeah,
how do you see you on happiness will measure your own happiness,
will sense if of successful failure?
Uh,
so yeah,
so that's part of it.
I mean,
uh,
um,
getting the food is great.
The food is,
the food at the food is my giant fan of Mexican food.
I love it.
There's a place down here that,
uh,
I take the guys here that work here all the time.
It is as Mexican as you get.
No one speaks English there.
They have a Mexican soap operas playing on the television and the food is just
sensational.
It's so good.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so,
so some of these things as well as that,
but,
but before you took him out this border between Mexico and the u s yeah,
it's,
it's a huge,
um,
is that vast difference between countries and cultures and I,
and the interaction,
another issue I guess is the issue of guns going south.
And we talked about lot other crops come up.
It was a god of firearms,
a lot of firearms.
Like that fast and furious deal.
Yeah.
Well the Eric Holder thing that went down years ago where they sold it was some
sort of a sting and they sold guns and those guns wind up being used to kill
Americans and even American police officers,
ea show.
So that was,
so the ATF or gone off this and this,
I mean the number of guns knows
how many guns have gone down,
but there was one study that,
and it came to conclusion at about two over 200,000 guns every year go from the
United States into Mexico.
So,
so that,
that isn't it.
That's an insane number.
200,000 guns.
And I interviewed a guy in prison in set up wireless for gun trafficking,
and he would drive every weekend from Mexico to the United States,
um,
by like 10 to 15,
mostly our fifteens some other guns as well,
and drive them down into,
into Mexico.
And it's pretty easy to get into Mexico.
So you drive them in.
It's like,
it's,
uh,
a piece of Piss is very easy.
You basically,
most of the time you've got no control.
Now he would actually hide them in fridges and in stoves and would pay an import
tax for the fridges and stoves.
Mm.
But,
but he was buying them and he said,
shit themselves.
And how did you buy the guns?
He said,
I would no idea to say what idea did you showed to by your guns?
or nothing at all,
said no idea whatsoever.
So no,
no,
nothing at all.
So did buy them from gun shows,
see buy from gun shows.
But then what he would do was he was used the private sale loophole,
which they're trying to close now.
So he would go in there.
And then I went to the guns to a gun show in,
in Mesquite,
in the Greater Dallas area,
known as the gun show captain of America,
and went to Gunshow there ad asked people,
can you sell me guns in our,
I've done live here.
Can you tell me guns?
And first I said,
oh no,
you need to be tasteless.
And someone said,
Oh yeah,
sure.
Consider these guns.
And it was,
the reason to get out is they say it's a private sale.
However,
some of them,
and I know some of the,
the,
the pro gun people get angry talking about this,
but I saw this with my own eyes.
They've got a whole bunch of boxed up EOF 15 rifles and they're sending them as
being private status.
So yeah,
private sale now he,
so he was just to simply buying these guns and taking them down.
I saw right in front of me as well.
Somebody who,
who,
who said to the person,
I can't,
I can't buy it,
was looking for different gun and said,
no,
I can't buy it.
I don't have,
I can't use it to buy the gun.
Um,
and the person will,
you know,
still happy.
Like even the private sale loophole if the,
if you,
in theory,
if you suspect the person is a criminal or we use them for criminal purposes,
you shouldn't sell him the gun,
but they don't care.
And so one thing,
I mean,
you really want to,
people really want people who they could,
it could be ms 13 undocumented.
They can still walk in and buy guns and some of these places.
Um,
but then,
yeah.
Um,
so that's,
that's a,
that's a big issue as well.
Yeah.
Those gun shows are pretty bizarre.
You're walking around with a bunch of people just itching to shoot somebody.
They're just hoping somebody breaks in their house.
I know a guy who keeps a gun and his ankle at all times.
He keeps one in his back.
He's got a,
he's got a holster that he carries with him.
Sometimes he carries a knife is what I mean.
He's literally begging for someone to fuck with them.
Mm.
I've got no problem with the people who like,
uh,
and I,
I talked to a guy from the Alaska machine gun association.
He had,
he has about 200 guns in his basement.
200 guns.
Wow.
And I'd have a problem with,
with,
uh,
with people with doing that,
but then there's still like,
how do you stop the Gun's going to criminals the same,
the gun,
the criminals in Baltimore.
Um,
I also interviewed in Baltimore or gun trafficker who,
who's taken guns into the city of Baltimore.
The,
yeah,
the gun show loophole is very strange.
It's very strange.
That's allowed.
And this is coming from someone,
me personally who owns guns and I believe in the second amendment and I just,
I don't think that the way to stop people from doing illegal activities is to
make those activities illegal for people who don't do anything illegal.
You know,
I think they're,
the real issue is the psychology behind people that are willing to shoot people
in the first place and the deal with the overall mentality of these human beings
and try to figure out what's wrong with our society.
Curate at a base level,
at a,
at a human level,
that's what's really wrong.
It's not the inanimate object of a gun.
That's the problem is the human beings that are willing to use these guns to
commit horrific acts.
That's what I think.
But when you have something like drug cartels,
which or gangs
which exists,
and then you have this thing called a gun show and then you have this gun show
loophole,
well boy you got a fucking giant hole in your damn.
You know you got water pouring right through,
right?
They're like,
how do you not fix that up?
If you are a person who believes in second amendment,
you believe in legal and responsible gun use,
you should be angry at that because that,
that represents a gigantic problem.
And that also represents a threat to legal gun ownership.
Because if this keeps happening and people keep getting outreach and more mass
shootings happen with illegally acquired guns after a while,
you know there's,
there's,
it's going to come to some sort of a,
a real conflict with people.
Yeah.
I'm actually doing a new book about gun trafficking.
Um,
so I'm really interested to hear about his issues and on what the actual room
for compromise is all log.
We know someone like yourself who believes in the second amendment.
How much room for compromise do you think there is in on these issues?
I may like closing the gun show loophole.
The other thing,
like for example,
the issue of 50 cals.
Yeah.
Laugh 50 cows in Mexico,
the cartels,
cartels,
he's 50 cows.
They used them to set up ambushes.
They'll use it to hit a military vehicles,
please vehicles.
So they're,
they're the seller side of a mountain and there are 50 cows and go back and bang
and I go right through it.
They're like baseball size bullets.
It's crazy now.
Massive.
Quite that big.
But they're big ass bullets now.
Yeah.
And I don't understand that a lot of these myths completion,
military are corrupt as well.
But you know,
if you are an honest one or whatever,
you're going in a,
in a car and he's fucking hit by one of those guns.
Your vehicle,
the now open up on you.
So is there any room there do you think for like,
um,
clamp down on 50 cows?
I've never heard that discussion that much.
I have a friend who was one and see Anthony Kumina.
He's got a 50 caliber.
It's ridiculous.
It's crazy.
I mean the idea that you're using that for self defense,
unless you're going to war with Russia or you know,
fighting against some gang cartel gang,
that's a invading your city.
That seems that's a military weapon.
I mean it's the same argument I think for uh,
having a,
a fighter jet with Hellfire missiles.
Do I think you should be able to own a Cessna and fly a little prep playing
around?
Sure.
Okay.
Do I think you should be able to own a jet?
Well,
I mean there are a lot of rich folks with private jets.
Okay.
Do I think you should be able to own a fighter jet that goes the speed of sound
or,
oh,
I mean it's just a faster jet,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you think you should be able to own a fighter jet with 50 caliber guns
strapped to it?
Oh,
well what the fuck is that?
Are you starting a war?
Like what are you doing it?
This is like these levels that things get to,
you know,
um,
that's this.
There's the argument against a t automatic weapons or you can't use automatic,
like certain states have regulations in terms of what you can and you know,
in California you can't even have a silencer.
Um,
I don't know why because it's very bad to have that loud bang of a gun.
It's terrible for your ears.
And if you're a hunter or,
or someone who likes to shoot target practice
or something,
that's a terrible thing for your ears.
And there's a suppressor that get put on the end of the barrel and will mitigate
that.
But for whatever reason,
I think mostly because of films and public perception,
people think that those silencers are only used by assassins or something like
that.
Are you using to kill people?
So do they,
they get it.
They convert the,
the semiautomatics from the states in Mexico,
they convert the fully automatic yes
here too.
And then of course,
you know about bump stocks,
which makes it much more,
um,
free with the trigger.
I'm much,
much easier to fire rapidly rather.
So how do you feel about the issue?
You know,
one of the issues is of having a,
uh,
a database like the ATF or they're not allowed to have a searchable database on,
on guns in the United States.
So they have like,
they have like paper files and stuff they go through still and they can't have
like a digital database on guns.
That seems ridiculous,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
I mean you think they think I'm a bit,
I guess the,
these are the gun lobby.
See the idea of a guy in a registry as being a step to taking away their guns
because um,
like once you start registering that you can go then afterwards and say,
well we know where the guns are or whatever,
but how do you feel thing there's flexibility on that issue of like the gun.
I've liked having searchable databases.
I mean like with a car,
like you have a license plate and if there's a hit and run you just type it in
and you know whose car it is within seconds with gun tracing you can't,
you know,
you find a gun at a crime scene,
whatever.
You can't just trade it in or put a button,
your Guy Bang.
That is,
they have to go through paper.
I have to go through a whole formal trace and go through this kind of search.
She then there's flexibility on that issue as well or,
or how do you feel about that yourself?
Well,
I've myself field,
there should be a traceable database.
I mean if it's just like a car and a glad you brought up that analogy because
when you,
when you get a car,
you have to know how to drive a car.
You have to,
in order to have a license to drive a car,
you have to take a test,
you have to take a written test and you have to take a physical driving test
with an instructor.
They have to see and think about how many more people drive cars then own guns.
So it's possible to do this with guns yet it's not done.
When I bought my first gun,
they're like,
here you go.
It's like what?
Like that's it.
Like yeah,
you're not a criminal.
Look,
we did a check check on you.
You're not a criminal.
Here's a gun.
And I bought a pistol about a 38 revolver.
That was my first gun.
And I went to the gun range and practice with the gun and I read about how to do
it and I talked to an instructor about safety and put goggles on and ear muffs
and you know,
make sure you're protected and how to properly hold the gun while you shoot it
and all these different things.
But it's stunning to me that you don't have to do that.
I mean,
you can own 150 guns and know how to operate zero of them and they're all yours.
You,
you don't even have to prove,
you know,
what the fuck then safety is.
You don't have to prove,
you know,
anything that's,
that's crazy.
But not me.
It's fun to shoot guns.
I'm not a,
since I've been doing research with new pickup and shooting a few guns in
places,
I wa I went
over to Serbia and arrived in Serbia on a hangover.
I'd see my friends in the UK and got drunk with them and arrived in a hangover
and I'd met,
uh,
the contact dancer.
I wanted to go to a gun club and he took me into a nuclear bunker.
And Find Ak 47 just came off the plane.
Wow.
Me.
And it was like,
wow.
They had a crazy,
I said,
whatever you want to fight at a crazy amount of guns there so I can see it's,
it's,
it's fun to fire these things.
Do you think they actually are good in self defense?
I mean,
do you,
do you actually think,
I mean,
I don't know.
It makes go.
I don't have guns.
Um,
I don't,
I wouldn't,
when I travel in the field,
um,
I won't go security.
Um,
they'd generally security is going to be more of a hindrance because they're
attracted attention.
Yeah.
Tried to attention and you've got to go basically what my hands up and send it.
This is it.
This is me.
It's what I'm doing.
And most of the situations there,
you've got to have a lot of people with heavy guns.
You're not going to our gun.
These guys.
Yes.
In Central America was a bit different in Honduras.
They were,
I was with guys with guns.
They're not out of choice,
uh,
of,
of choosing security because the,
the,
the journey's himself was Karen a gun.
And had friends carrying guns and he was in,
he was carrying a mini UC was driving his journey.
His friend of mine or Lean Castro's name is Greg,
Greg Ernest.
He was driving around and he had a mini UC,
um,
on,
on his lap as he was driving around to crime scenes and running around doing
stuff.
Um,
but do you,
do you think guns are actually effective for self defense?
I mean,
do you have guns for self defense and believe in that?
I would simply just enjoy the sport of shooting guns.
Well,
I hunt in,
uh,
one of the things I have used,
although I archery hunt.
Now most of the,
most of the hunts I go on when I,
when I go to these places to uh,
to bow hunt specifically.
Um,
but I have rifles for hunting.
I have hand guns for self defense in it depends entirely on the situation.
That's like saying,
do you think cars are effective to get you where you want to go?
Well,
they are effective.
If you drive carefully and you,
you know,
use the blinkers and look when you change lanes and you know,
make sure you observe the speed limit and all the different laws and are aware
and don't crash in anybody.
But if you're an asshole,
no,
they are not effective.
You're going to wind up dying in a car accident.
You're going to flip your car over in the side of the road.
Um,
if you're in a terrible situation,
it is better to have a gun then and not have a gun if you know how to use it,
if someone's breaking into your house.
There has been,
there's countless stories of people protecting their families from,
from bad guys when they have guns.
They,
these are real stories.
They do exist.
There are people that I've talked to,
they,
you mean you can find them.
There's countless stories.
There's also countless stories of people leaving their guns,
uh,
unlocked and a child,
a child gets a hold of it and kills himself accidentally.
There's,
there's stories of children accidentally killing their mothers.
there's all those stories too.
So Ken,
a gun be effective in self defense for sure.
That's why
the military used them.
That's why police officers use them.
That's why people train and they go to the range and they take tactical courses
to learn how to use a gun for self defense.
Absolutely.
A gun can be used for self defense.
It's the best thing for the best tool for self defense.
Other than,
you know,
obviously living in a good neighborhood,
having a uh,
uh,
security alarm,
all these different steps.
A dog dogs are good,
especially at dogs as a trained dog.
But yeah,
guns absolutely can protect you.
If you're in a situation,
someone breaks in your house and you shoot that person dead,
that's you.
You're safer then that person killing you.
That has happened.
But it's a decision that me,
this is a gross generalization.
That's an entirely dependent upon the situation that you find yourself in.
But if you're not,
if you're not protected by,
uh,
if you,
if you don't understand how to use it,
if you're not trained,
if you don't,
if you don't have training to keep your shit together when things go south.
Because when you're in a situation and your life is in danger,
if you've never been in a high pressure situation before,
how do you know you can keep it together and even hit something you're aiming
at?
People have wild trigger panic and they have a really hard time dealing with
life or death situations if they haven't served in the military or have been
some very,
very high stress situations.
We have to learn how to control yourself under extreme pressure conditions.
There's a lot,
there's a lot of factors there.
But I would say the same thing as like you,
you would also say that with martial arts.
Like can you defend yourself if you know martial arts?
Well,
depends on what you know.
I mean some martial arts or fucking horseshit you,
you,
there's a lot of people out there practicing nonsense.
And if someone who actually knew how to fight just punched him in the face,
they would be doomed.
And then there's other people out there that are experts that would be very calm
if someone tried to fight them and they would know what to do and what not to
do.
And if the person wasn't armed,
they would be able to easily dispatch them.
It really is dependent upon the situation,
how much effort you've put into it,
how much thought you've put into it.
And,
but there is a lot of people out there that if you broke into their house,
you're making a huge mistake because they are trained and prepared and ready
because they don't want to be a victim.
And it doesn't mean they're bad people.
And I think we,
we have a problem in this country where we look at things.
They're very binary there.
One or zero there,
good or bad.
Guns are bad.
Guns are always bad.
I don't want to go on God.
God put bad guys.
Take your gun sometimes.
Sure.
Sometimes,
sometimes you kill the bad guy and you protect your family though too.
That's real too.
Yeah,
no,
I have respect for people having,
having guns for self defense.
We were talking about that shooting.
I've been around a few shootouts in Latin America and uh,
and over in Haiti.
And one thing about that from,
from a journalist point of view and being around,
and I've been seeing a lot of violence as well,
a lot people fighting.
Um,
even going back to England,
people having physical fights,
um,
or with knives and that kind of thing.
So one of the differences I think with guns is,
and it's funny,
you can't see bullets is as I said,
it's such a,
it's a,
it's like a small thing,
but like you can't see the thing that's hanging when you see a guy with a knife,
right?
It's like the guy's scary.
You can see,
you can imagine that knife sticking into you,
but the gun is like you were seeing,
you know,
the object,
you can't see really that the polygamy in.
So one of the Times,
one of the Times I was in Haiti and I went in to cover the earthquake in 2010,
which was,
you know,
real sad,
like crazy amount of debt day.
And we were covering the looting,
um,
afterwards and the police came and started firing right into where people were
looting and was with a camera man.
And the police were fine,
Bang,
Bang and [inaudible] and it drew in his same situation.
Not,
not right in that scene there,
but in another scene they shot and killed somebody.
The police just firing at the looters and all the Lucas started running when the
police or fire,
I note a foreign going with the,
how high were they firing when they were firing,
you know,
Bang.
Finally split that.
And a camera man I was with was just sat down.
He was like filming this.
And I think this is one of the problems that wildlife,
cameraman get shot in these places.
You start feeling like you're watching on TV.
Oh Wow.
Cause you feel like,
you know,
you're seeing the lasing loud is amazing.
Look or look at what I'm watching and you're seeing this and this.
Let not saying run,
we've got to go like the fire.
And he was like,
was like,
it's like we got to get the shot.
We got a go.
Ah,
there's a,
there's another sad,
sad thing of a,
of a,
of a guy filming,
uh,
American journalist called Bradley wrote and will,
in a rest in peace who was killed in Mexico back in 2006.
And he was filming a shooting in state of war Hakka and he filmed these guys
shooting and he fell and was hit and it carried on filming.
Oh Wow.
He filmed his own death.
I mean,
you can literally see there.
Um,
yeah.
Sad has worked for news agency when that,
that day when he was,
when he was killed in,
yeah.
There's a lot of courageous camera people and you know,
they get locked into that job and it becomes normalized.
Almost like you were saying,
the people that live in these war torn areas,
it becomes a normal way of life to them and all their,
there are a lot of murders.
If you're there on a daily basis,
it seems like almost like a regular life.
A lot of these cameramen,
I mean they're courageous people.
You see these guys who go over to war zones and film what's going on in
Afghanistan and you know,
and I've met some of these guys,
there's just,
it's a crazy way of life to just accept the fact that you're an observer that
might be a victim and you're capturing all this.
So people like me can get,
uh,
some semblance of a perception to what's going on in that part of the world.
I went to the Philippines,
southern Philippines and saw the fight against the Islamic state there,
uh,
in end of 2017 and it was interesting seeing that compared to the violence I
cover normally in,
in Mexico.
So that was isis.
They took over to city morale.
We,
and it was an error.
They caught it.
It was,
it was interesting,
was more self contained.
They had,
uh,
an area called the main battle area,
the MBA thing,
may main battle area.
So in that area was isis and the Philippine army just done that at all the time.
Just like constant bang,
Bang,
Bang and planes going over and bombing.
But actually,
even when you're outside that main area,
even if you're,
you know,
we were just outside it and even if you're like 600 meters or 600 meters from
it,
but it's,
you're not in the fighting,
the fighting is over there.
Whereas in something like Mexico,
South America locked on this fighting is kind of happening everywhere.
There's no real control over Wayne where the main battle area is.
But there,
they didn't really let any journalists inside,
like deep into the main battle there and didn't really let any journalists in,
was sitting outside and hearing just constant ricochet of gunfire and,
but sometimes bullets will come out of the area.
So there was an Australian guy and I think he bent over to pick up some cookies
and a bullet hit him in the neck.
Um,
uh,
saw the x ray actually the bullet embedded in the side of his neck and Nestle,
it takes taken out and he was so it must've been at the end of its terminal
velocity.
Yeah.
So it must have been a far,
far,
far shot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That went through something else for it hit him.
Yeah.
So,
so he,
so yeah,
maybe it didn't go into fast though that crazy though.
I didn't.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it was kind of a of beans.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think so.
Kay.
He was okay with it or that guy's lucky.
Yeah.
It's shot in the neck and you are okay.
So,
but,
um,
but yeah,
in terms of,
you know,
some of the people who've really been in a,
um,
there was,
they would,
they had a,
one of the guys,
um,
one of the police special force guys had a camera on his helmet and he went,
he showed me that footage and he was right there.
Right inside they're going,
they're like really,
really close buildings fighting with Islamic isis people.
And it was the same techniques I talked to the general and he had a big chart
showing how the techniques of guerrilla warfare had evolved from like Fallujah,
Aleppo,
Mosul,
and how this kind of weird new form of guerrilla warfare they have of like
fighting house to house.
Um,
so there'll be besties is suicidal kind of guerrilla war.
They rise up and there'll be like,
you know,
super close fighting really close.
It was,
and then when the bond they'd hired in like in a basement and stuff and they,
they drill holes in the walls so they can fire through and fight through.
And the footage he had,
he showed me the footage he had from being like Ryan side,
close up,
like running literally in a room,
Bang,
taking these people out.
And it was like,
wow,
this just crazy.
I was trying to persuade the guy to let me pull that footage out there.
You know,
it did look kind of crazy video game,
kind of cooler warfare.
So could've offered article called call [inaudible].
Judy could,
could,
could have Judy.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
Mexico right now is almost like a war.
you can call it a drug war,
but because there's no,
it's not like an army versus army more.
We don't think about it that way.
But from,
in terms of the amount of violence that goes on over there and the amount of
casualties it rivals,
anything that's going on in the world right now.
Yeah.
So I'll be talking a lot about this over the years and with some experts is a
good writer called Robert Bunker,
who's an external research if it a Pentagon and he investigates this stuff.
There's a guy called John Sullivan from here in California,
was a police officer who also did a bunch of research and you know,
got like a doctorate in,
in,
in starting all this stuff as well.
Talk to them about their ideas about what this means,
you know,
what is the,
uh,
um,
how can we define this in terms of warfare,
you know,
how's it fit in?
And they directed me to one,
a book by an Israeli historian called the transformation of war.
And this was written back in the early 1990s,
and he basically predicted then you're going to see a transformation in,
in,
in war and armed conflict around the world.
And in our,
we have like nuclear weapons,
um,
but they're useless in these situations and a nuclear weapons.
You can't use a nuclear weapon to solve the problem in Mexico.
You can't use a nuclear weapon to deal with Islamic state,
uh,
in a,
these internally insurgencies in countries.
So if you look at and Mexico,
so kind of weird,
hybrid hybrid says soap with tween crime and war.
So I use the word crime Wallace in some of these places,
say my Mexico,
El Salvador,
Guatemala,
Honduras,
where you have now,
maybe there are some situations in Mexico where it be,
you know,
the Co,
there was a group who called the helis go new generation cartel,
somebody,
a guy shot down and military helicopter using an RPG seven.
Wow.
Uh,
and that killed eight soldiers and a federal policeman in the helicopter.
There was one shoot out,
which involved 2000 federal police and five hungered security.
It was like 500 cartel hitmen had this crazy battle.
Mitchell can sometimes you actually get acid starts to look more like a kind of
regular conflict.
But generally it's all,
you know what way more kind of hybrids.
There's kind of weird mix.
And Taj trying to get my head around is for a long time,
for some years I was trying to thinking or is this a civil war?
Should we look at it?
And then it becomes okay this.
And then it was,
we know Robert Bunker when heat,
when I talked to him one time and he said,
you know,
like this doesn't fit into these theories in,
he's not quite war.
It's more than crime.
It's a weird hybrid in between,
um,
to kind of crime war.
And that's the way you got to understand these,
these things.
But a lot of the conflicts amount of world today,
these are spreading.
I mean,
you look up Somalia,
you look at Libya,
you look at a lot of these places,
it kind of weird mix instability.
And then this is what a lot of refugees are fleeing from.
And,
uh,
I was down in,
um,
to Kuana,
Christmas I fired the migrant caravan that came through Mexico Central
Americans,
you know,
which caused a big,
a big storm here that Trump kind of here before the election.
What was that like or is that overblown?
Uh,
I think it was a big deal.
Um,
was it a publicity event?
Like,
cause that why they were doing it and making it such a big deal and everybody's
walking towards the border.
Like there's a bit more than that.
I think there w uh,
there was,
um,
there,
this caravan,
it started a few years ago and they started off in Mexico for security.
Um,
there was an issue back a few years ago where the cartels would kidnap migrants
en masse.
They will just get loads of migrants and you think these people are poor,
how can they make money from them?
But they'd get them,
put them in camps and they know they have family in the United States.
So they say,
okay,
we've got 50 people in the camp.
We want $5,000 off each one of you off your family.
Like give us number,
we're going to call your family.
Okay,
send us the money.
That and then sometimes they'd agree on,
okay,
2000 you know like,
but so sounds like you know you're making money out of poor people,
but you do it on mass.
You do it 10,000 people and you get a couple of thousand dollars each.
That's like $20,000 200 to 200 minutes.
I told her $1 million,
so they started doing caravans for strength to avoid these mass kidnappings.
What was different about the latest caravan?
The actually became,
became a caravan crossing borders.
It used to be going through parts of Mexico together.
Then they started crossing borders.
Now the caravan began in October,
around October 12th and there was a call for them to meet and my friend all lean
again though the journey's done in Honduras.
He was down there filming with his TV crew putting on TV or they're down here,
they're going on this caravan.
It's only when boom and like Lowe's,
people saw it on TV and they're like,
I'm going,
I'm leaving,
I'm leaving now.
The desperation was so heavy in a,
Honduras isn't a real meltdown kind of stage.
Honduras is bad Venezuela's worse,
but Honduras might be like number two,
far,
you know,
real meltdown cases in Latin America right now.
So people were like,
no,
talk to some of these people.
They would say that I saw on TV and I was,
that's it.
I'm going to decided right away,
I'm going to get my bag,
I'm going to go.
So they arrived at the,
when they went through and got a mile into quite a miler in,
they became big like 7,000 people,
um,
arrive at the,
at the border with Mexico and you know,
first of all they try to,
they,
there was a,
a push and shove on the board and tear gas was fired and they went down and
cross the river in some of them walking across with a rope.
Some of them go across on tires.
It was kind of crazy scene in the scene.
Now there was squatted half the bridge and the now kindness.
It was kind of kind of a big deal.
I know the idea of calling them an invading army and so forth was,
was,
was obviously overblown,
but like I think it was significant scenes,
quite storic scenes that were happening down there.
And what was the overall goal to make it through to the United States?
Yeah,
I'm in a different people at different ideas.
It was kind of on his weird things,
you know,
like it was girly nights,
days.
Now some people had no idea where they will go and had no real plan.
Some people [inaudible] had very clear,
um,
cases of being like I'm a refugee.
Um,
in our understanding a bit about refugee legislation and not fleeing very
specific cases where they've been targeted by gangs,
working with corrupt police who want to kill them,
who have like hacked them and they've run and like I want to seek refuge in the
United States or in Mexico,
someone them seeking refuge in Mexico,
which is not the safest place to see each.
I like,
there's been cases of people who have one camera man or know who fed Honduras
and then was killed in Mexico.
Has there ever been any discussion of the United States military intervening and
trying to do something about the cartels?
So there's been like a us,
um,
you know,
some US forces like us marshals,
um,
sometimes they're like,
you didn't,
Mexico's very proud of its constitution and very proud of its sovereignty and
doesn't want us force acting in Mexico.
And I think the,
the,
the kind of idea really of,
of US military military's pretty out there.
How is pretty,
uh,
you know,
like it wouldn't help if he's be bogged down into more problems and,
and there'd be nap time in Mexico Ford App,
but there have been some cases of us doing some kind of activity in Mexico.
Like for example,
when they went off to chapel was man,
when they got him and there's a big shootout.
No,
they've gotten the first time I said without shots fired and,
and then he went to prison.
He escaped that one escape from her.
He says keep more than once.
Right.
And escaped twice.
Yeah.
Did he get helicoptered out once?
Nothing.
I'd to have been a happy and how he called down,
which is crazy.
He had the one tunnel escape with the electric bike,
which was crazy.
Yeah.
The,
when he went to the John and went to the bathroom,
we just step behind the door and he's gone.
That was insane.
It was really weird when I went to New York right now,
seeing him in the court in New York,
like seeing him in the flesh after all these years covering this stuff.
And I saw him and it was like,
Oh,
I've been to his village before.
I talked to his mother,
had stayed the night with his cousin in his village.
Wow.
Up in the mountains.
Uh,
you know,
seen.
What's it like up there?
It's um,
an eye,
quite a rugged mountains as Sierra Mar that is like a,
you go in a car up and uh,
unlike,
we are now in a four by four serious off road,
up and down.
And
there's people we know wandering around.
They're fully armed guys like ski mask,
Hmong guy like camouflage gear,
cammo gear key Moscot AK 47,
just like,
or not quad bikes,
just driving around the area.
Wow.
And we went up there with a colleague and a photographer,
have soy for Time magazine.
And we went up there and drove it to the village and I bought a bottle of
whiskey thinking to,
to kind of offer to the,
to the family member to say,
Oh,
you know,
here's a,
here's a bottle of whiskey to,
and when we arrived there and uh,
and he said we could stay at his house.
And I bought a bottle of whiskey so they know his and he said,
we don't drink in this house,
we're Christians
if we take drink.
And this is nice guy.
And he was like evangelical Christian wow cousin.
And he was,
we'd sit there talking and he'd be like,
quoting the Bible well and come and stuff.
And he knows like the exams are not understanding.
And there's a church,
it's an evangelical church right there,
which is supposedly built by chapel,
which is mother goes to right in front of her house.
And we sat through a three hour evangelical service.
I'm sitting there with,
you know,
Chapos mum there and all his family members were sitting there and the cars.
And even said,
oh,
we've got some friends here,
cause he got,
he was,
he was basically what he said,
like,
he stay with me,
you know,
you're my responsibility if something happens,
I'm gonna have to pay for this.
So we're like,
yeah,
we're not going to behave ourselves in,
in the village.
And he said to the chair,
to them,
we want to have also have what,
we have somebody from England here and somebody from the u s and come out in
this,
in this church ceremony.
So yeah,
yeah.
Really,
really bizarre scenes up there.
And there was so bizarre to,
but did you talk to them about the contradiction of being an evangelical
Christian,
being involved in essentially a mass murder and drug running operation?
So,
so the cousin is supposedly,
and he was like a cattle ranch and now I don't exactly,
you know,
obviously he's,
he calls,
um,
you know,
he,
I didn't know how much he might have been involved in the past,
but his,
his,
he says he's,
he's,
he's a farmer there and the mother,
um,
Chapos mother who's 88 or was 88,
they're now,
it's like 89 90 now.
Um,
you know,
she talks about her son with kind of pride it,
I did it and I didn't push too hard and there was a gunman around and stuff.
I didn't like [inaudible].
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I mean they,
this is,
this is their way of life.
I mean these,
these are,
so seeing him in the court,
um,
was kind of bizarre seeing,
you know,
seeing him right there.
And in New York,
in Brooklyn,
you know,
right there in Brooklyn and they bought it.
All of these crazy characters is p as a cooperating witnesses.
They brought in 14 cooperating witnesses.
I'm on a bunch of other gangs.
How does they protect those people?
Yeah,
I mean heavily,
heavily protected.
I mean,
I think,
I think it was ethically very questionable why they bought a lot of those people
in.
Um,
they were,
they brought in one guy whose nickname is Jupiter Petta who confessed himself as
many as 150 killings and maybe did a lot more,
uh,
and,
and he makes a deal,
likely makes a deal to cooperate against their chapters.
So you get into a kind of weird intrigued there,
um,
about what the government was doing.
This whole case is,
there's a history in this country with the prosecuting the mob,
John Guardian,
Sammy the bull Gravano who so admitted murderer and talked about the murders
that he committed and still they allowed him to get free day one.
His want to hit John got his lawyer was one of the lawyers for our chapel.
Of course.
Yeah.
And then they head out to the,
that they got something to do with these lawyers there.
It was a crazy kind of show.
Yeah.
It was weird.
It was like in a New York and this show they were putting on there.
Um,
it,
I felt kind of disconnect with the things I've been seeing over the last few
years.
And it didn't really,
why was it in New York?
The United they indicted him and a bunch of places and I think they chose New
York for the reason they wanted more of a show.
Wow.
I think,
I think they,
and they,
they,
they bought in a more than 50 witnesses,
you know,
three and a half,
three months of Crile.
Uh,
what was his defense?
So they originally tried a bit of a defense of,
they wanted to go back to fence of how there's a kind of government conspiracy,
um,
of like showing things like fast and furious that you mentioned like saying,
oh,
how come the government's trafficking guns,
two cartels and one of the witnesses had before one of the witnesses against
him,
it before use this weird defense called public authority saying he had
permission from the United States government to traffic drugs are basically
saying there's a kind of conspiracy involving in Mexican government's tardy,
corrupt and working with cartels.
The U s government is corrupt and working cartels and having very specific
agencies and El Chapo was kind of a full guy that they're putting this blame on
now.
That didn't really the gut,
the u s prosecutors shut that down.
And the judge,
they just said,
you can't talk about this stuff.
You can't say that.
So I went fast and furious,
came up,
they said,
no,
you can't talk about it.
You can't talk.
You can't,
who couldn't talk about it in a court?
Well that's ethically ambiguous,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a real thing that happened.
Yeah.
So there was,
you know,
we can't talk about it as you add to that.
And then the defense tried a bit,
well they had audios of El Chapo and they said,
Oh,
do you know how you noticed him?
And is he really the main guy in the law cartel now?
There is as well.
Um,
very possibly he's not the top guy in,
in Arcata.
They might well be another guy called miles and bother who's the number one?
And he might be more of an emblematic figure,
but for some reason El Chapo became the most famous in the world.
And so this other guy's,
he's still free.
Yeah,
What is his name again?
Myo.
Zambada.
Uh,
and where's he?
I knew somewhere in mountains.
Mezcal throws in the mountains often many.
What are these,
these weird things you'd think?
Like if you're a drug lord and you've got all of the money,
you know,
you've got millions,
billions,
they say,
let's say hundreds and millions.
I think they exaggerate how much money some of these guys have individually.
But then you could go anywhere in the world.
Do you think you could go somewhere out?
But these guys tend to be in their places that they,
they're,
they're people.
Like some of these people are people who are very educated.
I mean a chopper who's,
as a kid,
he was carrying sacks full of oranges to sell almost an education and they start
handling hundreds of billions of dollars that do dealing with a billion dollar
international business and they've got the capacity to understand and deal with
that.
But at the same time,
they still really hyper local in some ways.
They're still like people who,
they understand their world,
they understand it from their environment to control them,
become masters of their environment,
um,
to become kind of powerful in,
in that place,
who in that place.
But you know,
they couldn't,
you know,
the idea of them go into like sitting in Italy in a cafe and kind of running it
from there and they don't,
it's kind of beyond that would have to be there near the business because
otherwise someone would just take it over,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that's how many have to run that thing with an iron first.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could,
you could think though,
or maybe like,
yeah,
I guess so.
He really get your Christian cousin,
you won't rip you off.
Yeah.
But how am I also,
how much money do you need to make?
Right?
Taking you get out.
Maybe when it,
again with corruption,
I mean there's the issue of like a lot of police in Mexico poor,
so that's why they take deals.
But there's uh,
an ex governor called Thomas,
he Addington who I met a few years ago when he was governor of Tamaulipas state
and uh,
again,
he was not only taking money from drug traffickers after he left being governor,
he got into drug trafficking himself and he's like,
you think,
well once you made couple of million,
right,
do you need to make an art 10 million?
But then again,
governor,
the same with,
I don't understand the business we've been,
this is what does it,
what's the incentive?
Why did they think they always want to make more money?
I don't know.
I mean we were talking about that recently with Jeff Bezos when we found out he
has $150 billion.
Like when do you just say we're good,
we're good.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I think it becomes,
it's a game more than it is anything else.
Like there might as well be playing Parcheesi or monopoly or what they're trying
to win.
You know,
they're trying to constantly win.
And also you have an obligation because you're a CEO of this company,
so you,
you're running this enormous business that's earning money for all these other
people as well.
It's all very complicated though.
That has to do with a lot of psychological where
people can't put things into perspective and they get caught up in the race.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I guess,
yeah,
maybe drug traffickers are thinking that same thing somebody does when they're
making.
And then also that like,
like,
you know,
people have explained to me involved in this world,
they make a lot of money,
but they spend a lot of money.
While these numbers are wrong,
knock with chopper.
They said,
um,
his worth $14 billion.
That's what the US government said.
In that case he's worth 14 billion.
But then he's,
you know,
peerless bay to me,
you,
you know,
14 billion is when you take the value of drugs.
You'll send Hee Hee.
He trafficked and you're adding the opera singers,
$14 billion worth,
but really all the time you're paying back suppliers,
you're paying people off your own money and you know,
and you know you're buying hippos and chats,
cold covered rolls Royces.
Yeah.
There's some of that.
I think some of that was,
might have been exaggerated with him.
He had a lot of kind of more like middle class houses.
Oh yeah.
I went to one of the last,
the last hideout he was caught and it was more like a middle class.
It's just a normal house in a house,
but he'd have a lot of those.
What the fuck happened with Sean Penn?
Yeah.
Why was Sean Penn up there talking to him?
That was so strange.
Yeah.
The photograph was Sean Penn and shaking hands with them and then Conor McGregor
wore that same t shirt and it took that same pose on when he was,
when he was a got of fight.
Eddie Alvarez,
I believe it was.
Yeah.
What was that about,
like why was Sean Penn visiting him?
Yeah.
Bizarre moment.
I mean you have a,
an actor who's played gangsters areas right there.
Yeah.
I'm an actor who's played gangsters with a gangster who they're having,
you know,
movies made by him.
And there was a woman that Sean Penn knew that hooked us all up.
But I'm just gonna steal the,
she's a famous Mexican actress.
Yeah.
So,
so the story,
the whole story started there.
She is.
Yeah,
I've got them all power on around hey me with a murder.
Yes.
I nice to be married to Madonna.
So the story started,
so Kate,
the Castillo who you see there,
she was an actress in a TV series about drug traffickers,
which have now become a huge deal in Latin America.
They called out like telenovelas means like soap operas kind of thing,
series TV series and the whole badge them made about drug traffickers,
which are really popular.
And she was in one called La Reina del Sur,
the Queen of the south.
And in that she played this drug trafficker and afterwards in some kind of weird
moment afterwards,
I think she was like really into her role and stuff.
She came out with this message,
she wrote saying,
I'm in a Mexico is in such a disease,
such tragic situation in Mexico.
Um,
you know,
why don't they come in a drug traffickers common like um,
traffic with love.
I trust you more than I do the government.
And these are kind of sentiments that some people have,
but you know,
it was kind of a strange thing kind of bit of an out there thing for,
for a TV star to say.
And then Chapo,
El Chapo apparently became kind of enamel with her seeing her on TV and they
started this kind of communication.
Now Sean Penn then got involved in this and was like Ah,
in,
I'm going to go there as well and we can talk about the idea,
but the end of the tens of the meeting was as well talking about making a movie
or TV series of his story and our chapel giving the rights to Kate.
The Castillo in Sean Penn was kind of involved in this summer.
Now Sean Penn is a bit of discussion that now that Sean Penn and Kate del
Castillo fell out over this.
They have different versions of what happened there.
But you know,
Sean Penn decided to go and write this story for rolling stone about how to
experience,
yeah.
So they went then and his meeting was arranged and they went up to the mountains
and when that photo was taken and I,
they eat at that point that he didn't actually give an interview to Sean Penn,
but they had a dinner and had a meeting up in the mountains and,
and then left.
And then there were meant to afterwards,
there was then a big attempt to hit chapel,
but he escaped.
So that's when some people say that the Mexican government had followed them in.
I use their,
their trace or try and get to a chapel,
but he did escape.
He almost got caught close to there quite soon after as by escaped.
That's makes sense.
I mean,
how else would Sean Penn be able to slide through?
Is a famous actor.
I bet he doesn't even speak Spanish.
Yeah.
That housing daggy does.
I mean,
I don't know if,
so if he was followed.
I'm not saying that he was,
um,
in any case,
in any way deliberately.
No,
I leading them there,
but it's something that I think about all the time.
I think about,
okay,
if I'm going to meet criminals,
um,
am I being followed?
Um,
and am I going to lead,
you know,
what's my connection with Laura force much conviction with criminals.
It's a very difficult thing that I've been bantering and thinking about for lot
of years.
So anyway,
the Chapo escapes,
um,
and then said he couldn't meet up again for the interview because he was,
it was too hot for him.
So they made this video interview where he was sent some questions and he
videoed himself answering the questions,
which is kind of interesting.
It was the first kind of statement he made and he said,
I know various things.
I've been doing it since I was 15.
It didn't really give much away.
And then he was caught and when he was caught they were like,
we've got to move to stories.
And then the story came out large bang after he was caught in early 2016 so it
had to have some sort of an impact and then catching them.
I must've,
I mean,
it's possible.
Uh,
makes sense.
It's possible.
I mean,
chopper thing was pretty,
you know,
he'd already been caught before he was caught in 2014 was imprisoned,
escaped in 2015 through that tunnel and then was caught again in 2016 so yeah,
me maybe it had an impact on United on that when they were looking for them.
Yeah.
They were looking for him and he seemed,
he seemed to have lost a lot of his protection in a he before.
And I go back a few years.
I know he had enormous protection in and there's mountains.
I mean,
in a village you see there's a house above,
like there's a,
there's kind of a main clearing where his mother's compound is in,
so pretty basic still that village then are up from there.
You see a,
um,
a house on a hill and apparent that as well.
Chapter for long time.
He said,
don't just stay in that house.
Um,
in,
uh,
in one is in the run.
In the past,
he had so much protection.
Anytime the military will come close at the mountain,
you've got hundreds of people in radio saying that if they were coming up,
I'd get clear,
man,
what a crazy world you study.
Really.
It's,
uh,
it's amazing.
I really appreciate your coming here and talking to me about this.
And,
uh,
this book is El Narco.
Do you have more books are available?
Yeah,
she'll say my first book sell narco.
My second book is a gangster warlords,
uh,
which also has,
um,
stuff on their ms 13 on the gangs in Brazil,
the gas in Jamaica as well as Mexico.
And I'm working on my third book now.
And the third book is about,
about gun trafficking.
Hmm.
Well,
listen,
man,
I really appreciate your time and that you,
you've lived a very,
very fascinating life.
Stay safe out there,
man.
Great to be here.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thanks man.
Thank you very much.
Wow.